Test 1, 2.
Seid ihr alle drauf?
Ja.
Klingt auch hartweißanstrengend. Wer ist schuld am fahren? Das Camp ist schuld.
Also, wollt ihr die Wirt heiz wissen?
Ich war zwei Monate nicht in diesem Sender und schon passt mein Passwort nicht mehr an den Rechner. Das ist schon sehr erstaunlich, wie schnell man hier vergessen wird vom Computer. Ihr hört Chaos Radio, den Computer Blue Moon bei Fritz und wir werden uns in den nächsten nicht mehr ganz drei Stunden bis ein Uhr mit einem wunderbaren Thema beschäftigen, das uns alle viel angeht, das uns alle immer wieder interessiert und das heißt Microsoft. Viel Spaß dabei. Durch die Sendung führt euch übrigens der Chaos Computer Club. Wer das heute genau ist, werden wir gleich hören. Und schon hier am Mikrofon.
Hallo! Auf Wiedersehen! Bis dann, tschüss.
So klingt das dann nämlich.
Das ist alles Betrug, was ihr lest über MP3s. Der Spring. Was wir hören sind legale, natürlich legale MP3-Tracks. MP3 wieder ein anderes Thema, was wir hier im Chaosradio schon vor Jahrhunderten abgehandelt haben. Jetzt kann man in der Bild darüber lesen und da steht dann drin, alles umsonst und alles natürlich ganz gefährlich. Ist aber gar nicht unser Thema heute, jedenfalls das ist Musik. Das sind legale MP3s. Falls direkt von MP3 kommen oder?
Ja.
Hast du auch eine Ahnung, wie der Künstler heißt?
Müssen wir mal nachschauen.
Haben wir gerade nicht parat.
Ach ja, Urheberrechte sind euch egal, ne?
Wir können ja gleich am Anfang schon mal Asche über unser Hauptstreuen. Wir haben nämlich leider die Musik zu Hause vergessen und das ist jetzt hier ein Notfallprogramm, deswegen sind wir so ein bisschen...
So, erste Regel im Radio, nie sagen. So was war ja wozu? Hätte niemand gemerkt.
Ja, natürlich hat keiner gemerkt, aber haben wir doch gar nicht nötig, oder? Na gut, Johnny ist sowieso unschuldig, also es ist vollständig unschuldig.
Immer unschuldig an allem.
Genau, nur verantwortlich ist er.
Wer ist denn heute da, fürs Chaosradio?
Ja, ich bin Felix, ich bin hier schon ein paar Mal da gewesen und ich vertreue heute den Standpunkt, dass Windows schlecht ist.
Ich bin Frank und ich versuche ein wenig zwischen den streitenden Fronten zu moderieren und gelegentlich zu sagen, dass Mac OS auch nicht so schlecht ist.
Ja, und ich bin Pawel und ich bin der Meinung, dass Microsoft eigentlich ganz in Ordnung ist.
Also wir haben lange gesucht, bis wir jemanden gefunden haben, der einen Standpunkt vertreten wollte. Und wir sind Pawel Dedacbar und werden versuchen, nicht so böse zu sein heute.
Vielleicht gibt es ja irgendwie, vielleicht sollte man anfangen damit mal, es gibt die Leute, die es mit Computern beschäftigen, die werden natürlich die Diskussion kennen, Microsoft gegen den Rest der Welt. Wir werden versuchen, wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Intro erstmal zu geben oder für die Leute, die sich vielleicht mit diesem ganzen Imperium nicht so richtig auskennen, die immer nur lesen Will Gates, reichster Mann der Welt und so weiter und so fort. Wir werden versuchen, ausgewogen zu sein.
Ganz am Anfang wollten wir erstmal darauf eingehen, warum die Sendung fast gar nicht stattgefunden hätte heute.
Das Camp, genau.
Ja, soll ich das kurz machen? Wir haben ja vom 6. bis zum 8. August in der Nähe von Berlin in Adlandsberg. Kannst du ein bisschen leiser tippen. Wir haben einen Camp, wo wir ein paar Tausend Hacker auf der grünen Wiese haben werden, mit Internet und Strom und einem Raumschiff, das es zu reparieren gilt, dass da Not gelandet ist und unserer Hilfe bedarf. Wir wollten nochmal alle Leute herzlich einladen. Es ist noch nicht alles ausverkauft, was an Karten da ist. Es ist noch eine gute Chance, in der Tagesgasse ein paar Karten zu bekommen. Es wird sicherlich ein äußerst bemerkenswertes Eingangswerden, ganz in der Tradition der HIP, die hier vor ziemlich genau zwei Jahren stattgefunden hat in Holland, wo ich glaube so 1500 oder 2000 Leute auf der grünen Wiese waren. Wir werden möglicherweise, wenn das Wetter gut ist, dieses Mal ein paar mehr Leute da haben. Und es wird nicht nur ein Event werden für Hacker und irgendwie Computerbegeisterte, sondern wir werden eine ganze Menge Sachen da haben, die alle möglichen Leute interessieren können. Wir werden da eine schöne Badestelle haben an einem großen See. Wir haben da Partyzelte, wir haben da irgendwie Entspannungsgelegenheiten, also alle möglichen Dinge, die für einen Hackerurlaub im Freien irgendwie geeignet sind.
Kommen die Holländer auch rüber wahrscheinlich?
Die sind schon da.
Die sind schon da? Oh, wer muss denn die Behaarbergen alle?
Die Behaarbergen sich hier so einigermaßen.
Was gibt es denn noch? Ihr könnt an dieser Sendung natürlich auch wieder teilhaben. Wir haben einen Fritz Chat, den ich auch sehr lange nicht benutzt habe. Ich hoffe, der ist da noch, aber ich nehme mal an.
Wir sind schon drin. fritz.de slash speakers Nee, slash V-Chat.
Ach, slash V-Chat, genau, das ist dieser Java-Chat.
Im Übrigen, viele Größeren Parken sind nach Wien. Der hört uns da per Real Audio.
Dann sagt man jetzt Sachen, die er dann erst in 10 Minuten hört. Man kann einfach schneller chatten. Was gibt es noch zu sagen? Mehr Info übers Camp gibt es natürlich auch auf den Chaos Computer Club Seiten. Und zwar unter www.cccde.de slash camp.
Aber man kann auch auf www.cccde.de gehen. Da sieht man diese hübsche kleine Rakete mit dem Zelt. Und da klickt man einfach drauf und dann ist man da. Zur Beachtung, es gibt da ein neues Feature, nämlich das Feature Availability Chart. An dem zu ersehen ist, wann welche Features auf dem Camp verfügbar sind, weil extrem viele Leute schon gerne vorher kommen wollten und beim Aufbau helfen wollen. Und das wollen wir natürlich auch sehr gerne, weil je mehr Leute zum Aufbau kommen, desto schöner wird es halt. Nur man sollte sich diesen Chart angucken, um zu gucken, dass man nicht vielleicht zu früh kommt und möglicherweise noch gar nichts da ist, außer ein paar weidende Kühe, die da auf dieser Weide stehen.
Das ist völlig okay. Da kann man ein bisschen Kühe gucken.
Genau.
Ein bisschen Natur. Natur ist das, wo die Sachen wachsen, ohne dass man sie vorher programmiert hat.
Nehmt man auch den großen blauen Raum übrigens unter Computerlöten. Weil da kommt man drauf und da ist oben immer so blau.
Weißen.
Gut, ja, wir sollten vielleicht mal sagen, Real Audio, wo man das empfangen kann.
Stimmt.
Auch über Fritz? Schritz.de, glaube ich, und dann irgendwo klicken.
Ach, das ist doch wieder eine Aussage, wie wir sie lieben. Ich gucke gleich mal einfach live, ob da ein Link drauf ist. Ansonsten ist es, glaube ich, www.fritz.de slash live.ram.
Stimmt, ja.
Ah, hier ist auch ein Real Audio Link auf der Homepage. Einfach www.fritz.de und dann findet man das schon.
Sag ich doch.
Chaos.org.de ist ansonsten unsere Mailadresse, die wir natürlich während der Sendung nicht lesen. Gibt es sonst noch was wichtiges Einleitendes zu sagen? Wir hören ein bisschen Musik und dann geben wir euch Intros zum Thema heute. Das lautet Microsoft. Microsoft Kommt davon, wenn man die Alben zu schnell laufen lässt. Ach, das kennt ihr ja gar nicht mehr mit den verschiedenen Geschwindigkeiten. Chaos ist eine Message sozusagen, hier live von der Love Parade, die natürlich für uns immer ein bisschen später stattfindet.
Was ist das für Musik? Pavel hat sich da wohl vergriffen mit den Tricks.
Ich hab gesagt zwei und sieben.
Aber es gibt ja die Gelegenheit nochmal den schönsten Spruch zur Love Parade. Bratwurst ist the key.
Wir können vielleicht gleich mal im Chat antworten, nein, das ist nicht Blümchen nach dem Stimmbruch.
Da hat doch gar keiner gesungen.
Ist ja langsamer gedreht, klingt schon besser.
So, das ist jetzt die Sieben.
Pavel fängt mal und erzählt uns, wie so Microsoft toll ist.
Na ja toll, mal nicht verteilt.
Also, ich würde sagen, lasst uns doch mal ein bisschen ruhiger anfangen. Muss ja gar nicht erst unterteilen. Gut und Böse, schafft es jemand von euch so einen kurzen Rundumschlag zu machen. Geschichte ganz kurz. Warum ist Microsoft so, wie sie heute sind? Wo kommt das her? Was haben die gemacht? Und was hat die in diese Position gebracht?
Das Problem ist, dieses Statement objektiv von sich zu geben, fällt schon ziemlich schwer.
Ich fang trotzdem einfach mal an damit. Bill Gates hat ziemlich früh, so 1976, 1977, einen Basic-Interpreter für den damaligen Altea-Rechner geschrieben. Das war so der Anfang. Für die damalige Zeit doch eine ziemlich ordentliche Sache, mit wenig Speicher auszukommen. Ein ordentliches Stück Arbeit hat er da abgeliefert. Und war dann so die Ansprechadresse, oder einer der wenigen, die damals Programmiersprachen für die aufkommenden Mikrocomputer geschrieben haben. Und die Betriebssysteme damals, da gab es hauptsächlich CPM von Digital Research. Und die haben dann aber leider ein bisschen geschlafen als IBM ein Betriebssystem für seinen PC suchte. Und dann hat Microsoft nur einmal gezögert und ist auf die zweite Anfrage von IBM eingegangen, ihnen auch ein Betriebssystem zu liefern. Und haben ihnen dann eine Lizenz, die sie für 75.000 Dollar gekauft haben, ein bisschen umgestrickt und dann als MS-DOS 1.0 mit dem ersten IBM PC rausgebracht. Und dabei ist es auch noch geschafft, IBM in den Verträgen ein bisschen über den Tisch zu ziehen, sodass nicht alle Rechte an IBM gegangen sind, aber dafür unheimlich viele von den Kisten wegen dem Namen IBM über den Tisch gegangen sind. Und quasi innerhalb von 12 Monaten war eben MS-DOS das Betriebssystem Nummer 1 im Mikrocomputerbereich.
Warum war das jetzt alles so erfolgreich und ging so schnell?
Wegen IBM. Weil damals hatte IBM 80 Prozent vom Großrechnermarkt. Und als man hörte, die bauen jetzt auch kleine Computer, haben natürlich alle gleich auch erstmal aus Gewohnheit IBM gekauft. Und da war halt Microsoft mit drin.
Kannst du mal sagen, warum die überhaupt kleine Rechner gebaut haben? Also da gibt es natürlich immer die schönsten Gerüchte in dieser Branche. Ich kann mich jetzt auch nicht verbürgen dafür, dass alles 100 Prozent wahr ist. Aber die Version, die ich gehört habe und relativ glaubwürdig fand, ist, dass sie ihre Großrechner nicht genug gewürdigt sahen bei den Kunden. Also es gab damals so eine Situation, dass man den Kunden Platten verkauft hat, die alle gleich groß waren. Es gab da drei große Festplatten von IBM. Und da konnte man von Hand justieren, wie weit der Kopf Bewegungsfreiheit hatte, der Tonabgreifkopf, der Magnetkopf. Und wenn man seine Platte von 11 auf 22 Megabyte upgraden wollte, dann hat man bei IBM angerufen. Die haben dann einen Techniker geschickt, der diesen Kopf justiert. Und dann hat man halt mit der gleichen Platte gleiche Hardware mehr Durchsatz gehabt. Also das haben die Leute damals gemacht. Mit den Leuten war alles noch so ein bisschen unbedarft. Und IBM hat sich gedacht, wenn wir jetzt so richtig schlechte kleine Computer bauen, dann glauben die Leute uns eher, dass große Computer das sind, was man haben will. Und deswegen waren auch die ersten Versuche, kleine Computer zu bauen, so auch nicht auf Zukunft designt, sondern am Anfang konnten wir halt wenig Speicher adressieren mit den Prozessoren. Und das war gar nicht, weil die Leute sich eben gedacht haben, weil die nicht gedacht haben an die Zukunft, sondern es war einfach nicht geplant für die Zukunft, sondern es sollte so ein Feldversuch sein, wo IBM eben der Welt zeigen wollte, dass man für Großrechenzentren nicht bei der Konkurrenz kleine Computer kaufen soll, sondern bei IBM große Computer.
Das macht aber unternehmerisch irgendwie wenig Sinn.
Nee, da gibt es auch mehrere verschiedene Varianten.
Der erste ist eine Variante, die dich gehört hat.
Also eine andere Variante, die es da gibt, ist, dass IBM da eine etwas größere Vision im Kopf hatte, nämlich ein mehr oder minder intelligentes Terminal zu bauen, mit dem sie halt auch ein bisschen mehr beim User machen konnten, aber die Leute trotzdem noch beim Großrechner halten wollten. Also einerseits dem Bedarf entgegenkommt, irgendwie das kleine Computer auf dem Schradloch ein bisschen was tun können, auf der anderen Seite natürlich die Großrechner-Vision noch am Laufen halten.
Na ja, es gibt immer so Sachen, die dafür und dagegen sprechen.
Und die Sache ist ihnen halt einfach ein bisschen aus den Händen geglitten. Merkenswert daran ist, dass es nicht der erste Ansatz bei IBM war, ein kleiner Computer zu bauen, nur dass es der erste Ansatz war, der nicht von der gesamten IBM Hierarchie irgendwie platt gemacht wurde. Und zwar deswegen, weil es mehr oder minder als Kommandounternehmen durchgeführt wurde, in einer ziemlich abgelegenen Facility. Und sie haben irgendwie kaum auf IBM interne Technologien zurückgegriffen, sondern haben halt einfach alles von außen gekauft, irgendwie seinen Prozessor von Intel gekauft und noch den Chipsets dazu und haben halt irgendwie absichtlich einen Prozessor und einen Chipsets genommen, die nicht so schnell waren, um genau dieses Problem mit dem der Mittelwehr irgendwie zu umgehen, dass sie da halt irgendwie ein Problem bekommen, wenn die PCs genauso schnell sind wie die Mittelwehr.
Das war der Grund, warum sie damals zum 80-88 gegriffen haben, der auch nicht viel billiger war als der wesentlich leistungsfähigere 80-86 damals. Und das war ihnen aber zu gefährlich, weil der schneller gewesen wäre als ihre zehnmal so teuren kleinen Rechner.
Das war ihnen vor allen Dingen deswegen gefährlich, weil sie halt fürchteten innerhalb von IBM wieder abgeschossen zu werden, wie schon glaube ich sechs Projekte zuvor einen kleinen Rechner zu bauen. Und sie haben halt einfach alles zusammen gekauft. Und eines der Dinge, die sie halt auch dazu gekauft haben, war halt irgendwie ein Betriebssystem. Und sie wollten ja ursprünglich halt irgendwie CPM 86 kaufen von Digital Research. Und das hat sich dann halt irgendwie nicht richtig ergeben, irgendwie aus diversen Gründen.
Ja, wo dann da Microsoft ins Spiel kommt?
Genau.
Ja, das machen wir gleich.
Wir machen nämlich gleich erstmal, was da jetzt vorkommt. Gehört Chaosradio, Computer Blumen bei Fritz. Nach den Nachrichten geht's weiter mit dem Thema Microsoft. Und natürlich werden wir auch mit euch dann viel telefonieren und viel diskutieren. Plauder, nee, nee, nix Musik, erst mal, warte mal. Wo ist denn Angermünde? Hier.
Wenn Fritz in Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
22 Uhr, 32, was?
Reise, die Bundesregierung will Israel und die Palästinenser bei ihrem Friedensprozess unterstützen. Das sagte aus Minister Fischer bei getrennten Treffen mit der israelischen Regierung und Palästinenser Präsident Arafat zu. Unterstützung, die notleidende Bevölkerung im Kosovo erhält rund 3, 7 Milliarden Mark internationale Finanzhilfe für den Wiederaufbau. Darauf verständigten sich Vertreter von über 100 Staaten und Organisationen auf der ersten sogenannten Geberkonferenz in Brüssel. Entscheidung, die Bundesregierung will die Opfer des SED-Regimes besser entschädigen. Das beschloss das Kabinett auf seiner letzten Sitzung in Bonn. Demnach sollen ehemalige politische DDR-Gefangene künftig einheitlich 600 Mark pro Haftmonat erhalten. Ermittlung, bei der Suche nach dem Gewaltverbrecher Dieter Zurweme hofft die Polizei auf einen Fahndungserfolg im Raum Hannover. Am westlichen Stadtrand werden strenge Straßenkontrollen durchgeführt. Ein Jäger gehabt, Zurweme vergangene Nacht bei Hannover gesehen zu haben. Fußball in ihren Halbfinale hinspielen. Um den UI-Cup trennten sich am Abend Trabzon-Sports der Türkei und der Hamburger SV mit 2 zu 2. Duisburg und der französische Vertreter Montpellier spielten 1 zu 1.
Wetter.
Nachts klar bis neun, morgen wieder sommerlich bis 28 Grad.
Verkehr.
Wir sehen keine Meldungen vor, wir wünschen gute Fahrt.
Das war Nicole Marquardt mit dem Fritz Kurzinfo.
Fritz präsentiert House Meister, Doorkeeper, Miss Yeti, Pepe Moreno, Lupo, Art of Frequencies Live.
Samstag, 31.
Juli ab 22 Uhr, Open Air am Atombunker Gransee, D96 Richtung Strahlensund in Gransee ab 1. Ausfahrt links ausgestellt. Nur eine Stunde Fahrt ab Berlin.
Man kann uns tatsächlich hinfahren, ich glaube, zumindest aus gut unterrichteten Quellen gehört zu sagen, dass dieser Atombunker nicht mehr genutzt wird.
Du meinst er strahlt nicht mehr?
Ich glaube nicht.
Woran wir hoffen, dass die Hannoverer Polizei nicht allzu viele Leute noch irgendwie erschießt bei der Jagd nach diesem Typen.
Microsoft ist das Thema im Chaos Radio heute. Computerplumon bei Fritz. Wir haben gerade gehört, das IBM, wann war das ungefähr?
Das waren...
82.
Ja, 82 müsste das gewesen sein.
82, also sozusagen zwei Jahre bevor dann der erste richtige PC auf dem Markt.
Man kann ja auch fragen, warum IBM überhaupt zu Microsoft gegangen ist, weil Microsoft hat damals eigentlich keine Betriebssysteme hergestellt, sondern die haben eben diesen BASIC-Links da vertrieben. Also es gibt eine Story, die sagt, dass Microsoft eben zu Digital Research gegangen ist und da war da keiner und dann sind sie eben dafür gegangen.
Nein, das war gerade gar nicht die Wahrheit.
Die haben einen Termin verkackt.
Das war die Wahrheit, das ist ein bisschen komplexer. Also die Wahrheit ist so, dass bevor diese IBM-Geschichte kam, war es halt so, dass der Markt halt ziemlich klar aufgeteilt war. Digital Research hat halt CPM gemacht, es lief halt auf den meisten Mikrocomputern und Microsoft hat halt Basic gemacht und es lief halt irgendwie auf den meisten Mikrocomputern. Und es gab mir halt immer so eine stillschweigende Übereinkunft, zumindest ist Digital Research davon ausgegangen, dass DR halt irgendwie die Betriebssysteme macht und Microsoft das Basic und keiner dem anderen jeweils an den Kran pinkelt. Und daran wurde sich im Wesentlichen auch gehalten. Dann kam halt IBM zu Microsoft und hat halt gesagt, passt auf, irgendwie wir brauchen noch ein Basic für den Computer und könnt ihr uns jetzt das Basic bauen? Und haben dann irgendwie gefragt, wo kriegen wir denn ein Betriebssystem her? Und dann haben sie gesagt, na, Digital Research, die bauen halt die Betriebssysteme. Dann ist IBM zu DR gegangen und Gary Kindle, der flog halt gerade mit seiner Privatmaschine und hatte den Termin verpeilt oder was auch immer.
Der war ziemlich im Stress und hatte sich nach zwei Jahren irgendwie endlich mal eine Woche Urlaub gegönnt. Und hatte auch die ersten Millionen in der Tasche und war ein bisschen entspannt.
Genau, er war halt einfach sehr entspannt. Und was man dazu wissen muss, ist, dass DR im Wesentlichen wie eine große Familie betrieben wurde zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Das heißt, seine Frau hatte im Wesentlichen genauso viel zu sagen wie er und die wusste halt einfach nichts davon, dass da dieser Deal sozusagen anstand und hat dann halt die IBM-Leute wieder nach Hause geschickt. Und dann sind die IBM-Jungs halt noch mal zu Microsoft gegangen und der ist halt irgendwie ein paar Straßen weitergegangen und hat halt irgendwie einen Interrupt-Händler gekauft.
Na, er hat erst zugesagt. Er hat erst einen längst zugesagt und dann hat er schnell unter Druck sozusagen von einem, der vorher schon mal ein Angebot gemacht hat und damit abgeblitzt ist, einen Kudos gekauft.
Das war im Wesentlichen so ein Test von Speicherplatinen eingebaut. Die böse Zungen behaupten, dass deswegen auch vorne dieser lange Speichertest immer noch bei einem...
Das war das, was richtig funktionierte. Das funktioniert halt so gut. Wer sich schon immer wunderte, wieso es ein No-ROM-Basic-System haltet, das Problem bei diversen PCs gibt, naja, das No-ROM-Basic wurde dann einfach von den Klonherstellern weggelassen, weil sie halt keine Lust hatten, Lizenzen an Microsoft für dieses No-ROM-Basic zu bezahlen. Und deswegen gibt es halt diese Phänomenal No-ROM-Basic.
Na ja, gibt es heute auch schon seit ein paar Jahren nicht mehr.
Na ja, aber ich hab noch einen Computer, bei dem es noch so ist.
Ja, ich auch, aber...
Na ja, jedenfalls, diese Geschichte ist halt irgendwie insofern interessant, als das Bill Gates sozusagen beim zweiten Mal, als IBM zum zweiten Mal kam, dann halt einfach seine Chance gesehen, halt einfach stinkendreich zu werden und halt irgendwie die Imperien untereinander aufzuteilen. Das zeigte dann halt auch irgendwie die weitere Entwicklung so. Also er hat dann halt irgendwie relativ schamlos Leute abgeworben, Technologie-Komponenten entweder geklaut oder aufgekauft, meistens geklaut oder nachgeahmt, wie es so vornehm heißt.
Also man darf nicht sagen, das ist nicht Microsoft spezifisch, das haben andere Firmen auch gemacht, das ist die tollste Story. Boerland zum Beispiel hat ja mal vor ein paar Jahren Hochzeit gehabt, da haben die halt Compiler verkauft und den ersten Compiler haben die einem armen Schwein aus Dänemark für, ich glaube, irgendwie eine fünfstellige Dollar-Summe abgekauft. Und das war dann Toro Pascal 1 und damit sind die Stinke dreig geworden.
Na ja, Moment, aber bis jetzt ist ja in der Geschichte noch nichts passiert. Wenn ich mein Auto zu billig verkaufe, ist das keine Schuld.
Ja, aber heute kriegt man, wenn du heutige Knibbel-Lizenzen anguckst, dann ist es schon ungewöhnlich, dass man seinen Program verkauft und nicht an dem Umsetzen damit beteiligt wird.
Irgendwann, so in einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt, war es halt so, dass Bill Gates dann begriffen hat, was für eine Macht er mit diesem IBM-Deal und dem DOS in den Händen hält und hat halt einfach die Monopolisierung des Software-Markets als das Ziel der Firma verkündet. Das hat er irgendwie nur einmal getan und haben ihm seine PR-Berater gesagt, dass irgendwie dieses M-Wort mit dem Monopol, das sollte man dann doch lieber nicht in der Öffentlichkeit aussprechen, weil irgendwie, da gäbe es ja Gesetze gegen.
Wie war denn der Deal mit IBM? Genau, also Bill Gates hatte das Betriebssystem, was er zusammengeklaut und zusammengeschust hat von verschiedenen Programmierern, zu dem Zeitpunkt, als er den IBM Deal gemacht hat. Hatte er das eigentlich noch gar nicht wirklich?
Na ja, da hatte IBM auch noch kein PC, von daher war es nicht wirklich schlimm. So, und was sie halt getan haben, war, sie haben einen Deal gemacht mit IBM, der sagte, dass IBM dieses System als PC-Los auf ihre PCs aufspielt und dass Microsoft aber das Recht hat, dieses Betriebssystem unter eigenem Namen, nämlich MS-DOS, an beliebig viele andere Leute zu verhökern. Was dann halt irgendwie der große Ränkrichtsstarter wurde, als halt das Clone-Business mit den IBM-PCs anfing und sie halt dann noch dieses Asset mit dem DOS hatten, dass sie halt tatsächlich das Standardbetriebssystem für diese Systeme hatten. Und dann fingen sie dann halt auch irgendwann ziemlich schnell an, dreckig zu werden.
Also was sie richtig gemacht haben, war eben, das nicht exklusiv an IBM zu verkaufen, zu lizenzieren, das MS-DOS.
Und sie haben es tatsächlich auch nie verkauft, sondern sie haben wirklich nur die Lizenzen ausgegeben. Das heißt, IBM dürfte das benutzen?
Ja, aber nicht exklusiv. Also sie haben sich das Recht einfach vorbehalten, auch an jeden anderen und direkt dieses Betriebssystem zu verkaufen. Das war das Eigentliche. Und dann hat sich in der Folge auch IBM einfach als zu langsam erwiesen, sowohl mit OS2 dann, das kam dann später so diese OS2 und Windows-Geschichte. Lange Zeit sind sie ja gemeinsam dann marschiert, weil so etwa ein Jahr später hat man dann bereits festgestellt, dass dieser Schnellschuss jetzt mit MS-DOS eigentlich Technologie betrachtet nicht so, oder? Wirklich einen Schnellschuss war das Problem war, dass bereits anderthalb Jahre später über zwei Millionen Rechner unter MS-DOS liefen und dass sie bereits da merkten, es lässt sich, es wurde bereits viel Software entwickelt und es ließ sich dann halt einfach nicht mehr ändern. Es war einfach da und es hat dann sehr lange gedauert. Also dann, es wurde bereits nach einem Jahr, wurde begonnen, den Nachfolger in Form von OS2 zu entwickeln.
Wobei OS2 noch echt eine eigene Geschichte ist.
Nein, man muss einfach am Anfang noch ein paar Sachen sagen. Also erstmal ungewöhnlich eine Sache ist, was IBM eigentlich sonst nicht getan hat, dass sie Microsoft in dem Vertrag das Recht gelassen haben, das weiter zu verkaufen. Das ist echt ungewöhnlich für damalige Zeiten. Wenn man mit IBM verhandelt, wird man eigentlich normalerweise gekauft. Und IBM ist auch deswegen lange Jahre vor Gericht gewesen.
IBM gibt es eine schöne Geschichte mit den sogenannten Non-Disclosure Agreements. Ein Non-Disclosure Agreement von IBM wurde mit einer Neutronenbombe verglichen. So ist es zerstört die Leute, aber lässt die Technologie intakt.
Und da muss man vielleicht sagen, was das ist, was ja nicht jeder. Also ein Non-Disclosure Agreement wird heute eingesetzt, wenn ich mit einer Firma rede und die überlegen, ob sie mich für ein Projekt einstellen sollen, aber trauen sich nicht mehr zu sagen, worum es geht, bevor ich unterschrieben habe, dass ich nicht weiter sage.
Das auch nie funktioniert.
Ja, aber das ist erstaunlich einschüchternd. Also der Wert eines NDAs ist heutzutage auch durchaus durch die Anzahl der Seiten bestimmt. Also wenn man so ein NDA von 100 Seiten kriegt und da steht IBM drauf, dann...
Dann muss man auf jeder Seite einzeln unterschreiben.
Also man muss auch sagen, IBM zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass die größte Waffe, die die haben, ist ihr Patentportfolio. Also IBM verklagt selten Leute wegen Patentverletzung. Aber wenn jemand kommt, das passiert ab und zu und will IBM als Bein pinkeln, weil die irgendein Patentmiss braucht haben sollen, dann greift IBM in die Kiste und kann also jedem sozusagen eine große Liste von Patenten vorhalten, die er auch verletzt hat. Und deswegen, die eigentliche Drohung bei diesen NDAs von IBM ist nicht, dass IBM man dann vor Gericht zieht, sondern dass die halt Patentrecht klagen machen und da...
Warum haben die sich damals auf diesen Q-Handel eingelassen? Weil das Zeitdruck?
Nein, die haben unterschätzt, wie wichtig MS-DOS werden würde, wie wichtig PCs werden würden. Das war damals alles überhaupt nicht so aus. Es gibt ein paar tolle Zitaten aus der Zeit, so der Digital-Chef meinte, er sieht ein Weltmarkt von sieben Computern und der IBM-Chef hat irgendwann gesagt, wozu sollte man Computer zu Hause haben? Also die haben einfach überhaupt nicht gesehen, welche Auswirkungen das haben könnte.
Sie fanden es nicht wichtig und als sie es gemerkt haben, war es zu spät.
Und wie kam es, dass die ganzen Clones, also die ganzen anderen Rechner, die auf derselben Technik basierten wie IBM-Rechner, aber halt nachgebaut waren, wie kam es, dass die da nachgebaut wurden? Warum gab es da nicht Firmen, die selber PCs entwickelt haben?
Es gab extrem viele Firmen, die versucht haben, auf Basis desselben Prozessors halt andere Systeme zu entwickeln, mit unterschiedlichen Bussystemen und so weiter und so fort. Und die sind halt aus den unterschiedlichsten Gründen alle ziemlich sammeln und klanglos eingegangen. Der wichtigste Grund war halt, dass sie einfach mit den Preisen nicht mehr mithalten konnten, weil halt irgendwie nachdem IBM einmal angefangen hat, große Stückzahlen von diesen Einsteckkarten zu kaufen, war halt vollkommen klar, diese Steckverbinder für diese Einsteckkarten sind billig, irgendwie die Chipsetze für diese Einsteckkarten werden billig, weil es halt schon einen großen Markt gab. Und in einen großen Markt reinzukaufen, ist halt immer wesentlich billiger als einen eigenen Markt aufzubauen, um Spenden zu liefern. Und da ging die Sache dann halt ziemlich schnell. IBM hat im ersten Jahr eine Million von den Dingern verkauft.
Wobei mit den Clones, das war, also bis dahin galt im Computergeschäft die Regel, dass man sich durch besondere Merkmale, Features abheben muss von der Konkurrenz. Deswegen halt diese ganzen verschiedenen Firmen. Dann kam ja Compaq auf die Idee, wirklich den ersten Clone zu bauen. Sprich ein Rechner, der wirklich bis aufs Bit kompatibel ist mit den IBM-PCs.
Außer, dass er keinen Reset-Knopf hat.
Und das hat halt dann so eingeschlagen. Eine Hürde galt es dann da aber noch zu überwinden, nämlich das BIOS. Weil das hatte, glaube ich, IBM, oder?
IBM hat die Patente auf das BIOS enforced. Das BIOS ist halt dieses Basic Input-Output-System, was dafür sorgt, dass man auf die Hardware, die in diesem PC steckt, anhängigermaßen sortiert zugreifen kann. Und dieses System hat IBM aufgrund der Software-Patente sich schützen lassen.
Beziehungsweise das Urheberrecht drauf.
Das ist doch eigentlich geschickt, weil man kann da eben keine Klose bauen.
Da sind die Kloner erstmal eine Weile nicht dran vorbeigekommen. Und dann gab es zwei parallele Efforts dazu. Der eine war von Compaq, der andere von Phönix. Compaq waren die ersten, die es geschafft haben, so ein Bios zu reingenieren. Das heißt, sie haben die Funktion dieses Bioses als eine Blackbox nachgebildet, ohne eine zweite IBM-Code zu verwenden. Und Phönix hat mit ziemlich viel Venture-Capitalaufwand, ich glaube es waren 10 oder 12 Millionen Dollar, die sie da reingesteckt haben, genau dasselbe geschafft. Und Compaq waren die ersten, die einen Klonen ausliefern konnten mit ihrem eigenen Bios. Und Phönix waren die, die haben keinen eigenen PC gebaut, sondern die haben dieses Bios an all die Kloner lizenziert. Und dann ging halt als Phönix, das Phönix-Bios draußen war, ging halt die Welle los, da war dann halt irgendwie kein Halten mehr. Und in dem Augenblick hat dann IBM auch begriffen, dass das Bios an sich da halt nicht zu kleiner Schutz war. Und sie haben halt alle möglichen fruchtlosen Versuche mit irgendwie Micro Channel Architektur und all diesen ganzen Kram probiert, um wieder irgendwie da einen Daumen drauf zu kriegen.
Und an der Stelle hat es dann IBM nochmal verzockt. Als es um den Micro Channel ging, haben sie es nämlich im Sinne, wie du vorhin mit den Festplatten geschildert hast, die Nummer versucht, weil sie nicht so kurze Innovationszyklen haben wollten. Haben sie den Micro Channel erstmal langsamer gemacht, als er eigentlich hätte sein müssen. Und sich dann überlegt, okay, und nach einem Jahr, dann legen wir ein Bit um und das Ganze wird doppelt so schnell. Und dann können wir die nächste Generation rausbringen. Was aber dazu führte, dass als sie dann endlich rauskam, die entsprechenden Compact-Rechner, da ging gerade der Wechsel von 286 auf 386 los, einfach mal wesentlich schneller waren als die IBM-Kisten. Und damit hatten sie einfach, weil sie nach alten Regeln gespielt haben, einfach auch ihre Marktführerschaft bei der Hardware verloren.
Was sehr interessant ist, diese Ursprünge von Compact sind ja, wenn er meistens aber nicht so genau beleuchtet und diskutiert, und dass dann so ein PC-Schrauber tatsächlich hingehen kann und digital kaufen kann, finde ich schon immer noch ganz schön bitter.
Auf der C-Bit laufen die digitalen Leute immer noch mit digitalen Schildkontrollen. Das ist eigentlich ganz lustig.
Bisher ist also diese ganze Geschichte eine Mischung aus Cleverness von Bill Gates und Dummheit von IBM.
Bill Gates war auch nicht von Anfang an, hat er sich schlau verhalten, aber er war am richtigen Punkt und hat einfach Glück gehabt. Also das IBM hätte auch zu jedem anderen gehen können damals, was irgendwann wäre nicht so viel heute natürlich.
Okay, dann muss man einfach auch Mut haben, so einen Vertrag zu unterschreiben, in der Hoffnung, dass er den auch erfüllen kann.
Aber das ist durchaus üblich in der EV-Branche. Das ist auch so unterschreiben, die man noch nicht in der Tasche hat, weil das sind halt dann Entwicklungprojekte.
Ich hab neulich mal ein Foto gesehen von Microsoft ganz am Anfang, als es so 12 Leute waren. Definitiv, ich kenn keine Geschäftsfotos von den anderen Firmen zu der Zeit, aber garantiert unter den top 5 der hässlichsten Firmen irgendwie. Unglaublich hässlich, die ganzen Leute.
Na gut, IBM sah auch nicht wirklich gut aus damals. Die Entwicklungslabs sind legendär dafür, dass da halt so seltsame Leute sind.
Die Adams Family.
Es gibt auch so ein Bild von den Cisco-Gründern, die heute auch eine relativ wichtige Firma sind, so Routerbauer. Und wenn man das sieht, denkt man so, da ist irgendwie der MEP festgeblieben geblieben.
Gut, die Geschichte geht halt weiter. Nachdem halt der Mac auf den Markt kam, 1984, merkte Bill Gates, dass langsam der Trend weg von der Kommandozelle ging. Dort hat er sich ein paar Xerox-Park-Ingenieure angefangen.
Vielleicht kann man das kurz sagen für die Leute, die nicht so mitkommen. Bis dahin war der Computer, wie wir ihn heute zu Hause stehen haben, oder wie ihn eure Freunde oder Bekannte zu Hause stehen haben, rein Kommandozellen basiert. Es gab ganz wenig Grafik, keine Maus, du hast eigentlich getippt.
Es gab halt nur ein paar Prototypen.
Bei den Autos, bei den Großrechnern hat man auch nicht getippt, sondern mit tatsächlich Lochkarten gearbeitet. Das waren Dutch-Systeme, wo man eben seinen Job abgegeben hat, und dann hat man irgendwann einen Timeslot zugeordnet gekriegt, wo ist dann der Job abgeordnet, und am nächsten Tag hat man das beim Drucker abgeholt, oder eine Woche später.
DOS kennt ja im Prinzip jeder Inhaber eines Rechners mit Microsoft-Windows drauf. Das ist das, was am Anfang kommt, und so bleibt das dann halt stehen, so wie es jetzt auch manchmal stehen bleibt, wenn ihr den Rechner hoch fahrt. Weiße Schrift auf schwarzem Grund, oder damals noch grüne Schrift auf schwarzem Grund?
Genau. Oder gar stemngelb, bei Luxus-Tunnels. Na ja, jedenfalls, der Mac kam raus, und der Mac war halt revolutionär. Es gab halt vorher zwei wahnbrechende Systeme, die halt irgendwie grafische Benutzeroberflächen hatten. Das eine war der Alto am Xerox-Park. Das ist halt so das private, irgendwie halte ich Forschungszentrum von Xerox, wo sie halt irgendwie 50 begnadete, wirkliche Ultraspitzenwissenschaftler zusammensperren und machen lassen, mit irgendwie einem Sack Geld. Das Konzept ist da wirklich ziemlich faszinierend. Also die haben halt tatsächlich 50. Diese Beschränkung auf 50 ist halt, weil der Projektmanager von denen damals meinte, also mehr als 50 Leute kriegt halt nicht gemanagt.
Xerox ist auch ganz lustig entstanden. Die haben den Kopierer als Konzept in der Tasche gehabt und sind auch zu IBM gegangen. Also IBM hat mehrfach tatsächlich total verloren. Und die haben gesagt, hier Kopierer, da kann man irgendwie Papier mit kopieren und Datenschutz, Dokumente und managen, toll. IBM hat gesagt, wer würde Dokumente kopieren wollen? Also das ist durchaus kein Einzelfall mit dem Übertriebsystem. Und der PC ist IBM, hat wirklich mehrfach direkt...
Das ist bei den grafischen Benutzern verpflichtend bleiben. Ja, also die haben halt, da am Xerox Park haben sie halt diverseste Dinge, unter anderem auch das Ethernet entwickelt und sie haben eine Seitenbeschreibungssprache entwickelt. Xerox Interpresset war der Vorläufer von PostScript. Es gibt bei Xerox halt irgendwie eine ziemliche Tradition, die ist so ähnlich wie bei anderen Forschungsinstituten heutzutage, wo die Leute halt irgendwie sind eine Weile vor sich hin forschen und dann frustriert davon sind, dass diese Forschungsinstituten nicht in der Lage sind, ihre Erfindungen ordentlich zu vermarkten und sich dann halt einfach irgendwie nach draußen begeben und halt irgendwie anfangen da selber zu agieren. Und da sind halt etliche Leute dann weggegangen, unter anderem einer von diesen Leuten, die halt sich mit Gruppenorganisationen und Software beschäftigt haben, ein Herr Simoni, der war halt auch bei Xerox und ist dann zu Microsoft gegangen und hat dann da dieses Programmierer-Mind-Control-System entwickelt, das Microsoft heute noch irgendwie verwendet, um halt irgendwie seine Programmierer unter Kontrolle bzw. unter Bildskontrolle zu halten.
Nein, das war ein Schuss in den Ofen. Das haben sie dann sehr schnell eingesehen, dass das nicht funktioniert. Also das war dieses Metaprogrammierer-Konzept, wo Bill Gates an der Spitze einer großen Pyramide sitzt und alle für ihn programmieren. Das war so irgendwie die Vorstellung. Das hat sich aber dann relativ schnell erledigt.
Es gibt auch schöne Geschichten von Programmierern, wo so bei Microsoft das Schlimmste, was passieren konnte, war, dass Bill Gates rumkam und irgendwie auf den Bildschirm guckte und sagte, ja, also an der Stelle, das machen wir jetzt aber anders und hat überhaupt keinen Einblick natürlich in den Querpunkt gehabt, aber kam sich halt immer noch vor, wieder große Programmierer, das geht halt auch zurück auf diese Zeit. Und da haben die dann halt wochenlang aufräumen müssen, um das wieder gerade zu liegen.
Sie haben halt am Xerox Park diesen Alto entwickelt, das war halt eine relativ revolutionäre Maschine, die hatte einen grafischen Benutzunterface. Und sie hatte eigentlich auch Ethernet, aber aus irgendeinem Grunde haben sie das dann doch erstmal eine Weile lang nicht eingebaut, weil die Leute bei Xerox das nicht so richtig vorstellen konnten, dass es nützlich sei, dann haben sie es aber doch eingebaut. Und der Alto war dann eine 30.000 Dollar Maschine, die im Wesentlichen alle Features eines modernen PC's mit einer grafischen Benutzauerfläche hatte. Nur, dass er halt irgendwie ausschließlich für den internen Bedarf von Xerox gebaut wurde.
Und da war Faktor 10 langsam als andere Maschinen auf dem Markt. Das war eine Research-Maschine.
Jedenfalls sind dann etliche Leute von diesem Team irgendwann zu Apple gegangen und haben dann halt da die Lisa gebaut. Die Lisa ist heute noch eine Maschine, die man wirklich als legendär bezeichnen kann. Sie war halt der erste industriell verkaufte PC mit einem grafischen Benutzerinterface, wo halt extrem viele Konzepte von Xerox realisiert wurden, plus ein paar eigene von Apple. Und die Lisa war sozusagen die Maschine, die halt irgendwie den, na sozusagen, den weiteren Weg von Apple bestimmte. Das einzige Problem an der Lisa war, dass irgendwie Steve Jobs, die nicht leiden mochte, aus irgendwie irgendwelchen Gründen.
Ja, und sie war zu teuer und brauchte zu viel Speicher und eine Festplatte.
Na ja gut, okay, sie war halt einfach teuer.
Sie kostete 10.000 Dollar bei der Markteinführung und ist halt total gefloppt, aber trotzdem sind alle Leute immer noch glücklich, weil sie es heute schaffen, auf dem Flohmarkt einen Kunden Lisa zu finden. Also in der Regel findet man keine. Und Steve Jobs hat dann irgendwie dieses Projekt komplett gecancelt. Da gab es dann bei Apple immer schon seit damals diesen Begriff gestieft, wenn ein Projekt irgendwie entsorgt wurde. Und hat halt irgendwie den Macintosh entwickeln lassen. Bei Macintosh war es halt so, Steve Jobs ist jemand, der wird halt da auch irgendwie beschrieben als jemand, der über ein Reality-Distortion-Field verfügt, also ein realitätsveränderndes persönliches Feld. Der hat halt irgendwie die Leute da echt angetrieben, den ersten Mac zu produzieren. Und der erste Mac hat halt nur 128 Kilo Byte Speicher. Und war halt irgendwie, hatte einen Bildschirm, der irgendwie großzügig betrachtet, etwa neben einer Postkarte im Sprach. Aber er hatte eine grafische Benutzeroberfläche und das Kettellaufwerk und der funktionierte auch.
Und eine Maus.
Und eine Maus und er grinste, wenn man ihn anmachte. Also er hatte schon mal alle wesentlichen Dinge, die man so haben musste.
Aber die ersten zwei, drei Jahre wurden die Mausschieber eigentlich eher belächelt. Und auch irgendwelche ordentliche Computernutzer, also Computer für Analphabeten hieß es damals auch. Aber irgendwann muss man sagen, da hat doch Microsoft auch wieder frühzeitig gesehen, dass da doch was dran ist.
Sie haben als erstes die Spreadsheets tatsächlich portiert und das war halt irgendwie der wesentliche Faktor, dass sie halt irgendwie Spreadsheets hatten. Das war ja schon beim Apple II irgendwie der Erfolgsfaktor und das hat irgendwie den Macintosh so lange gerettet, bis halt Adobe kam und Adobe hat dann halt irgendwie den Mac tatsächlich gerettet.
Man sollte vielleicht auch sagen, MS-DOS ist nicht nur deswegen erfolgreich gewesen, weil man da programmieren konnte, sondern ist vor allem deswegen erfolgreich gewesen, weil es tatsächlich weitgehend CPM-kompatibel war. Es gab sogar Binärtranslator an, das heißt Programme, wo man CPM-Programme genommen hat und dann hat man die durch dieses andere Programm gejagt und dann kam ein MS-DOS-Programm raus und das ist zum Beispiel mit WordStar gemacht worden. Und WordStar ist ein Programm, das so damals lustig war, weil es in 64 Kilobyte RAM gearbeitet hat und beliebig große Dateien editieren konnte, was Word bis heute nicht kann. Das sind einfach Sachen, die sind damals gemacht worden und der Portierungsaufwand war klein. Das heißt für eine Firma war es kein Problem, ein Programm nach MS-DOS zu bringen, was sie einmal für CPM entwickelt hatten. Man hat einfach 600 Dollar für dieses Konvertierungstool ausgegeben und dann war fertig. Deswegen war es einfach billig für Firmen, MS-DOS-Versionen anzubieten.
Es gab sehr schnell sehr viel Software für MS-DOS. Und dieses ist bis heute dann von niemanden wieder mehr geschafft worden, eine Betriebssystemplattform zu schaffen, wo einfach so viele verschiedene Anwendungen für alle Zwecke da sind. Und das war dann nämlich auch der entscheidende Punkt, weil IBM und Microsoft haben ja gemeinsam versucht, recht früh noch den Nachfolger zu MS-DOS zu entwickeln. Und irgendwann hat dann aber Microsoft dem im Prinzip einen Tritt gegeben. Und die Auseinandersetzung ging damals genau um die Frage, bleiben wir kompatibel? Und bis zu welchem Grad? IBM wollte gerne ein schönes Betriebssystem damals mit mit OS2 draufsetzen, was aber viele Kompatibilitätsprobleme mit sich gebracht hätte. Und Windows als Aufsatz einfach auf MS-DOS war erstens schneller fertig und machte für die bestehende Anwendung relativ wenig Probleme. Das heißt, es war eher so eine Smooth Transition, wo die alten Sachen immer noch weiter gelaufen sind und einfach kein Technologiebruch erfolgt. Wir werden alle anderen haben immer versucht, mit Innovationen, mit neuen tollen Dingen es besser zu machen.
Also das war nicht, weil IBM gerne ein tolles System haben wollte und die Kompatibilität nicht so wichtig fand, sondern das Problem war, es gab damals den 286er Prozessor, der einen technologisch großen Sprung geschafft hat, in dem er Protective Memory geboten hat. Das heißt, man konnte ein Betriebssystem schreiben, erstmalig, was Prozesse voneinander geschützt hat. Die konnten sich nicht gegenseitig im Speicher überschreiben und damit war es überhaupt möglich, ein System zu machen, wo mehrere Prozesse parallel liefen. Es war auf PC-Architektur, auf kleinen Rechner ein absolutes Novum und es hat jahrelang keiner benutzt. Es gab auch den Prozessor, diesen Kompatibilitätsmodus, in dem MS-DOS lief, aber es gab eben auch diesen neuen Modus, für Protected Mode, den wollte IBM dann nutzen mit US-2. Aber dieser Modus ist nicht kompatibel gewesen zu dem alten. Also das Problem war einfach, wenn man Protected Mode benutzt, konnte man nicht MS-DOS emulieren. Und das war auch der Selling-Faktor für den 386er.
Also das größte Problem war ja, dass IBM den 386er in US-2 ja gar nicht integrieren wollte. Sie haben ja mit Microsoft zusammen daran entwickelt und Microsoft hat gesagt, Jungs, wenn ihr schon jetzt anfängt, ein neues Betriebssystem zu schrauben, dann schraubt es bitte gleich für den 386er. Und IBM hat halt mal wieder Angst um ihre Mittelwehr gehabt.
Den gab es noch nicht, den 386er.
Da gab es den 85er. Als sie den die OS-211 zusammen entwickelt haben, war genau der Zeitpunkt, wo der 386er schon absehbar war und wo sie schon dafür entwickeln konnten. Und da haben sie halt gesagt, nein, sie entwickeln nicht für den 386er, weil sie halt kein Performanceproblem sehen. Also für ihre Mittelwehr. Und das ist irgendwie wieder mal so eine typische IBM-Geschichte. Sondern halt irgendwie lieber bewahren als vorwärtsschreiten.
Lass uns mal zurück zu Microsoft kommen. Wir sind jetzt im Jahr 85, 86.
Na, wir sind irgendwie kurz nach dem Erscheinen des NEX und 86 ungefähr.
Was ihr im Hintergrund habt, ist kein epileptischer Anfall, sondern dass das eine Tastatur klappert. Das ist unglaublich schnell.
Also der Chef freut sich ja auch in regelmäßigen Abständen über das Geräusch. Ja, die Tastatur ist doch laut. Das tut mir also leid an der Stelle, aber es gibt vielleicht auch so...
Gibt es denn auch irgendwelche Hinweise, Korrekturen, Hilfen?
Wir sind gefragt worden, ob wir was zu Xenix sagen, zum Beispiel. Naja, muss man vielleicht nicht machen. Microsoft hat also auch neben DOS andere Fehlgriffe gehabt, wo sie sich dann aber tatsächlich auch frühzeitig von entfernt haben.
Also die Sache mit der grafischen Benutzeroberfläche war halt irgendwie ein Trend, den Bill Gates auch gesehen hat. Und sie hatten halt einerseits dieses OS2-Projekt am Laufen, was sie dann zum Schluss ziemlich halbherzig betrieben haben, weil irgendwie sie gesehen haben, dass IBM da mal wieder sowohl technologisch als auch marketingtechnisch ein Problem erzeugt. IBM hat halt OS2 als einen Start-Tool gesehen für so ein Projekt, das hieß glaube ich Office Vision, war das glaube ich, was sozusagen versuchen sollte, diese PC-Flut einzudämmen. Und es war halt im Wesentlichen so gedacht, dass OS2 die Basis sein sollte für ein Softwareprodukt, das halt...
Für ein 20.000 Maniare Office Paket.
Ein 20.000 Maniare Office Paket, was halt irgendwie im Wesentlichen auf dem Hostsystem läuft, an das der PC angebunden ist. Auf dem PC läuft dann OS2. Und also sozusagen das, was man heutzutage unter kleinen Server versteht, also die Features, die man so mit kleinen Server und Microsoft Office und solchen Dingen hat, wollte IBM halt mit einem 3 Milliarden Dollar Entwicklungsaufwandssystem zusammenschußt. Und sie haben es halt total, wirklich total vermasselt. Das System lief nicht, performte nicht. Und das kostete irgendwie 6.000 Dollar Lizenz pro Arbeitsplatz. Und dann hatte sich die Sache dann halt im Wesentlichen erledigt. Und dann hat Microsoft angefangen, irgendwie Leute zusammen zu kaufen, um halt irgendwie Windows aus dem Boden zu stampfen. Und Windows flogte halt erstmal barbarisch. Also die erste Version, die halt irgendwie öffentlich verteilt wurde, war halt irgendwie, glaube ich, 3.0.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Also ich hab Windows 2.1 auf meinem Rechner gehabt und es gab auch Windows 1.0. Und Windows 1.0, also der einzige Konkurrent damals, Microsoft, hat aber keineswegs Innovation geleistet, sondern es gab vorher GAM und das war vom Atari portiert worden. Das war eine Oberfläche, da gab es auch schon Desktop Publishing Tools für, das war richtig fortschrittlich damals.
Wann ist das Atari Betriebssystem auf den Markt gekommen?
87, 86, 87.
Wir haben GAM gehabt, aber jedenfalls gab es GAM damals und es hat 16 Farben immerhin gehabt und war relativ hochauflösend, wenn man Monochrom benutzt hat. Und da konnte man tatsächlich Textverarbeitung mit machen, aber war kein Betriebssystem, sondern ein Aufsatz-Oftos. Und Microsoft hat deswegen auch einen Aufsatz-Oftos gemacht, der ein bisschen Grafik gemacht hat. Später haben sie gesehen, dass das kein Weg ist, den man haben will und haben NT angefangen und das sind ursprünglich über zwei Sourcen gewesen. Aber es gibt tatsächlich zwei Entwicklungen zu Windows. Erstmal Windows 3.0, die erste die man tatsächlich benutzen konnte, weil sie diesen Speicherschutz von 3680 so rudimentär unterstützt hat. Aber vorher war das tatsächlich nur, wir wollen auch ein bisschen Farbe und clicky-bunty. Und schon damals hat Windows keine Kompatibilität zu GAM gehabt. Also das haben die tatsächlich absichtlich nicht gemacht. Das ist auch ein Trend, den sie bis heute durchhalten, dass sie nicht so konkurrenzkompatibel sein wollen und sind, wenn sie nicht wirklich müssen. GAM war damals marktbeherrschend auf dem PC. Aber die Office-Pakete, die benutzt wurden, waren doch größtenteils textbasiert. Textmaker, Wordstar, Wordperfect, alles Texttools. Das heißt, GAM war zwar im Grafikmarkt beherrschend, aber das war nur ein kleiner Teil vom tatsächlichen Markt. Deswegen war Windows auch nicht gegen diese Office-Sachen gemeint, sondern tatsächlich als GAM-Konkurrent. Und GAM ist dann ziemlich sanft von der Bildfläche verschwunden. Dieses Jahr, vor ein paar Monaten, ist es als GPL wieder aufgetaucht. Die Firma hat sich gedacht, dass es noch eine GPL ist, genug Public License. Das heißt, jeder kann den Quellcode haben und rumbasteln. Man darf gespannt sein, was daraus wird. Aber jedenfalls Windows 1.0 war tatsächlich nur grafisch clicky-bunt. Und es war so langsam, dass man auf einem nicht 286er konnte man zwei Uhren haben, die dann nicht mal Echtzeit liefen. Das war tatsächlich nicht zum Arbeiten gedacht, sondern nur so, wie kann auch Windows 2.0 war dann schon deutlich besser, aber man konnte Fenster nicht überlappen bei Windows 2, sondern man konnte sie nur nebeneinander auf dem Bild schon haben. Und das war übrigens auch wie bei Jam. Bei Jam konnte man auch keine Fenster überlappen haben. Also Innovation war damals tatsächlich auf dem PC-Bereich erstmalig Windows 3. Und wieder mal war es so, dass die Versprechungen aber dem Tatbestand deutlich vorausgeeilt sind und geleistet hat dann erstmalig Windows 3.1. Das ist ja auch das, was man heute noch findet teilweise. Das war dann nicht nur eine Oberfläche, sondern es war auch so ein bisschen Betriebssystem und hat auch ein bisschen Speicherverwaltung gehabt im Gegensatz zu dem MS-DOS, wo man zwar allozieren konnte und freigeben, aber es war nicht dafür gedacht, dass mehrere Programme unabhängig voneinander Speicher haben wollen. Das ist so ein Problem, was man auch heute noch bei Mac OS sieht, dass die Programme bei MS-DOS immer den gesamten Speicher genommen haben und ihre Speicherverwaltung selber gemacht haben, weil die von MS-DOS so schlecht war. Und das heißt, dass die Programme einfach angefangen haben, immer den gesamten Speicher zu fressen und dann ist schon mal gar nicht denkbar, dass man mehr als ein Programm fährt, weil einfach schon das erste Programm alles frisst und es für das zweite nichts sah. Und beim Mac OS ist das...
Quarter Deck ist dieses Programm...
Ja, es gab dann so üble Versuche.
Quarter Deck war irgendwie recht erfolgreich.
Ja, war erfolgreich, aber naja gut. Jedenfalls bei Mac OS ist das heute noch so, dass im Header von Binary steht, wie viel Platz das Binary haben will und so viel kriegst du dann auch vom System. Und wenn es dann mehr haben will, dann muss man irgendwie übel klatschen. Frankfurt hat gar nicht mehr zu erzählen. Aber die Betriebssystem-Konzepte, die man heute so belächelt, sind tatsächlich damals entstanden. Und auch Windows 95 sind im Grunde nur ein Windows 3.1 mit ein bisschen aufgeburter Grafik. So von den Inhalten her ist das ziemlich das Gleiche.
Ja, die Sache mit den grafischen Nutzoberflächen... So, gut.
Ihr seid gerade so am Wegrennen, aber wir können ja erst mal ein bisschen verarbeiten lassen.
Genau, ein bisschen Musik.
Und zwar untypisch wird diese Sendung aber trotzdem auch passen. Neues für den Anschutz und Neubauten. Das mit den Handclaps sind jetzt nicht mehr die Neubauten. Es gibt eine neue EP von den einschlossenden Neubauten. Nach diesem Remix-Album Totally Eclipse of the Sun passend zu... Naja, zu son finnsteines halt, ne? Vielleicht nachher noch ein Stück davon, von Neues von den Neubauten, aber wir reden weiter über Mikroweich.
Genau.
Winzelweich.
Winzelweich, ja.
Genau.
Also fünf Jahre brauchen wir noch.
Genau, wir waren gerade sozusagen am Anfang der grafischen Benutzeroberflächen. Windows 3.0 war auf dem Markt und der Mac war immer noch viel besser. Es gab irgendwie...
Na ja, also auch die Bateable.
Ich meine, es war immerhin so, im ersten Macintosh hat Steve Jobs gemeint, mit 128k wurden sie schon hin kommen und die Ingenieure meinten, hey Steve, wir brauchen ein bisschen mehr Sprechen. Nein, 128k sind genug. Dann haben sie echt heimlich...
Da war übrigens echt visionär gegen, oder? Ich meine, immerhin 600.000 KM muss für alle reichen.
Das war später. Jedenfalls haben dann die Ingenieure heimlich die Fähigkeit eingebaut, um in Macintosh irgendwie mehr Sprecher einzubauen, nämlich noch 512k mehr. Und...
Ja, 84 war ja noch die große RAM-Preiskatastrophe, wo dann gerade pünktlich zur Einführung des Mac auch noch die RAM-Preise mal Faktor 2 bis 3 in die Höhe schossen.
Vielleicht kann man das mal vergleichen. Also heutzutage, wenn ich 128k RAM in meinen Rechner baue, kostet mich das 60 Mark.
Kannst du nicht mehr kaufen?
Zu klein. Also heute kann man...
Kostet mich das 60 Mark?
Also ich erinnere mich noch, als ich meinen Commodore PC 20, das war so einer der ersten Clones von PCs von 512 auf 640 Kilobyte geupdatet habe, da habe ich so eine Handvoll Chips gekriegt, die musste ich dann rauftun auf das Malverbot, das hat mich 160 Mark gekostet. Und das war noch als gerade echt günstig war in die RAM-Preise, das konnte ich mir damals leisten mit meinem Taschengeld. RAM war schon deutlich teurer. Und im Übrigen ist das, wie auch heute noch so, dass Großrechnerhersteller, obwohl es im Grunde die gleichen RAMs sind, da nochmal einen Ausschleif von so Faktor 5 machen.
Bis 12.
Bis 12. Also der Grund, wieso der Mac eigentlich überlebt hat, war Adobe. Sie haben halt einfach... Adobe waren auch wieder mal Leute vom Park, die halt irgendwie abgehauen sind von Xerox, die damals halt dann in der Presse gearbeitet haben und haben gesagt, okay, wir haben jetzt hier eine Sprache, mit der man Objekte, auch Papierseiten beschreiben kann, wo die genau sind, wie die genau aussehen und vor allem auch Buchstaben wunderschön machen kann. Und Xerox hatte mal wieder üblich, wie üblich, kein Interesse daran, das zu vermarkten. Also die Jungs hatten selber losgegangen, haben halt Adobe gegründet und haben halt Postscript entwickelt.
Also Ironie des Schicksals muss man eigentlich sagen, weil Xerox sollte eigentlich aus eigener Erfahrung wissen, dass man so Sachen dann auch mal risikomäßig vermarktet, wenn man nicht direkt sieht, was der Sinn ist. Und Xerox hat das nicht genommen. Postscript ist von ein paar Professoren gemacht worden und Technikern. Das ist eigentlich ein gutes Zeichen. Heutzutage werden Start-ups von irgendwelchen Marketingleuten gegründet, die halt irgendwie ihr Wirtschaftsdiplom gerade gemacht haben.
Die sich dann ein paar Programmierer suchen. Naja, jedenfalls gab es dann Desktop Publishing. Desktop Publishing war halt zum ersten Mal die Fähigkeit, Dokumente, die aussahlen, als ob sie irgendwie aus einer Druckmaschine kommen, um einen Computer zu machen. Parallel dazu war der Laserdrucker entstanden, auch wieder bei Xerox.
Wichtig vor allen Dingen, dass es auf dem Bildschirm schon so aussah, wie es nachher auf dem Papier auch aussieht.
Das war so ähnlich, ja genau.
Na das kam erst später, Display Postscript. Also Postscript tatsächlich dafür zu benutzen, dass man auf dem Bildschirm sieht, dass es sich so im Konsumer-mäßig, dass man es kaufen konnte im Laden, erstmalig auf Next versichert hat.
Technisch war das kein Bildschirmpostscript, aber weiß nicht, der Atari hat das ansatzweise.
Nein, die Idee ist älter, aber dass man tatsächlich, also dass das Programm gezwungen ist, mit der gleichen Sprache zu beschreiben.
Das interessiert den Anwender nicht. Was irgendwie wichtig war bei Adobe war halt, dass sie zum ersten Mal in der Lage waren, auf dem Bildschirm sowas ähnliches darzustellen, wie es dann auf dem Drucker aussah, mit Patchmaker. Das hatte dann irgendwie immer noch einige Abweichungen, aber es war so, dass man halt irgendwie den größten Teil der Drucksachen einfach machen konnte.
Also das interessiert den Anwender durchaus heute zumindest, sieht man einfach.
Heutzutage auch nicht.
Nein, aber man sieht einfach, dass die Leute sich fragen, warum sieht es hier anders aus, als wenn ich es ausdrucke. Und da steht zwar ein bisschen drauf, aber das heißt ja gar nichts. Also tatsächlich, die Garantie, dass es gleich aussieht, hat man tatsächlich nur, wenn man für Drucker und Bildschirme ansprechen, die gleiche Sprache benutzt oder die gleiche Methode.
Naja, jedenfalls der Siegeszug von Desktop Publishing führte halt irgendwie dazu, dass irgendwie die Macs überlebten. Ohne wär's wohl nix mehr geworden, denk ich mal. Weil das waren halt die einzigen Maschinen, die man halt kaufen konnte, auspacken konnte, anschließen konnte. Und halt irgendwie da irgendwie auf den Laserdrucker drucken konnte. Auch da hat Steve Floss mal wieder ziemlich ins Klo gegriffen, weil er hat sich irgendwie beharrlich geweigert, irgendwie Ethernet in die Kisten einzubauen. Und seine Ingenieure haben ihm dann halt irgendwann Apple Talk abgewungen. Das heißt also, ein serielles Übertragungsprotokoll, um die Laserdrucker anzuschließen.
Nee, das war, da hatten sie in den Macs den 8250 überall drin für die seriellen Schnittstellen. Und den konnte man halt noch ein bisschen höher takten und diesen Synchronprotokoll noch drauf fahren.
Na gut, aber zumindest funktioniert das. Und das war das erste Networking, was tatsächlich out of the box irgendwie bei einem Computer, den man in irgendeinem Laden kaufen konnte, funktionierte, ohne dass man irgendwas extra dazu brauchte. Das fand ich schon mal sehr beeindruckend.
Immer diese Äußerungen so, Schränk ein, Schränk ein, Schränk ein. Das war der erste Mac, wo man nichts dazu kaufen musste.
Na gut, ich meine, zur selben Zeit gab es irgendwie noch nicht mal Kürschbaum-Link, gab es noch nicht. Und Lab-Link gab es auch noch nicht.
Nein, aber das wären ja auch Sachen, die man dazu kauft. Du kannst tatsächlich auch damals einen IBM Rechner kaufen. Da war dann eine Tokenring-Karte drin und das funktioniert auch ziemlich direkt.
Tokenring zu der Zeit?
Na klar.
Ja, okay, stimmt, ja.
Na gut, aber nicht ohne Einiges an Konfiguration.
Tokenring ist relativ billig zu konfigurieren. Also da braucht man auch gar nicht irgendwelche Hubs oder sowas wie bei Ethernet.
Tokenring ist wie ja mal so eine typische IBM-Angelegenheit. Okay, wir streifen ab.
Also eigentlich wollten wir bei Microsoft meckern heute.
Genau, Microsoft...
Und eigentlich meckern wir heute nur über die Guten gerade so. Adobe wird irgendwie klat gemacht, Xerox wird beschimpft.
Microsoft hat halt irgendwie von all diesen Dingen immer ein bisschen zu spät mitbekommen und dann sind sie halt immer mit großer Macht eingestiegen. Also Bill Gates jüngster schwenkende uns halt 95 oder 94, als er dann plötzlich mitbekommen hat, da geht der was im Internet ab, da müssen wir uns mal drauf hängen. Ist halt irgendwie legendär geworden, er hatte in seinem Buch der Weg nach vorn, irgendwie kam das Internet noch nicht vor. Und irgendwie sechs Monate später, irgendwie hat er komplett die Company umgeschwenkt und gesagt, jetzt mal Internet hier.
Und heute erklärt der Vorgerecht, das ist schon zehn Jahre lang irgendwie... Also man kann meckern, was man will, das ist die richtige Strategie. Also wirtschaftlich kann man nichts dagegen sagen. Es ist genau richtig, den Markt in Ruhe zu beobachten, zu gucken, welche Firma so ein bisschen erfolgreich ist. Denn historisch gesehen hat noch fast keine Firma Geld gemacht, die ein Produkt auf den Markt gebracht hat. Sondern immer der erste, der es nachgebaut hat und der ganz viel billiger wurde, weil er die W-Seits-Kosten nicht zahlen musste. Das sind die Leute, die die massive Kohle machen.
Die machen halt auch mal die hässlichere Technologie.
Ja natürlich, aber das interessiert den Anwender nicht. Also wenn ich für ein Zehntel des Preises etwas... Ich auch.
Wobei...
Also ich hätte mir eine Lisa gekauft, wenn ich da...
Also Microsoft war schon meistens sehr schnell. Und sie haben tatsächlich der Industrie auch das Konzept, der GoodEnough Software schert.
Jetzt kommen wir zum eigentlichen Problem.
Hauptjetzt gegen Microsoft?
Geht doch nicht. Nein.
Das ist durchaus...
Da kann man nicht die Schuld Microsoft für in die Schuhe schieben, finde ich. Und es ist nun mal Fakt, wenn ich heute einen Brief schreiben muss, dann ist das... und ich habe halt eine Software, die das heute macht, dann benutze ich die und dann nützt mir die tolle, perfekte Software, die in sechs Monaten oder zwölf Monaten ich haben könnte, einfach überhaupt nicht.
Es geht vor allem um die Software, die es seit 20 Jahren gibt.
Das Problem ist doch vor allen Dingen, dass Microsoft ist eine Firma, die schon immer, immer, immer den Markt damit platt gemacht hat, dass sie behauptet haben, sie würden irgendwie in sechs Monaten oder zwölf Monaten irgendetwas rausbringen, was dann doch zwei Jahre gedauert hat. Also von daher ist das Argument jetzt für Microsoft zu schaffen, wenn das irgendwie irrelevant war. Ich meine, die Software, die es heute gibt, ist allemal schlechter als das, was es in den nächsten zwölf Monaten geben wird. Das ist wohl wahr. Plus die Software, die es heute gibt, ist zum Beispiel für mich heutzutage so schlecht, dass der einzige Teil, den ich benutze, PowerPoint ist, weil es dafür derzeit einfach kein Konkurrenzprodukt gibt, weil irgendwie alle anderen platt gemacht wurden.
Also ich mach meine Folien mit Tech. Excel ist scheiße, stimmt. Ist doch klasse. Excel ist einfach echt schlecht. Also wir können ja mal, ohne den Namen zu nennen, von dieser großen deutschen Mobilfunkfirma berichten, die mehrere Monate keine Rechnung zugestellt hat, weil sie ihre Kundenabrechnung tatsächlich mit einem 100 Megabyte großen Excel-Spreadsheet gemacht haben und da dann ein Makrovirus drin war.
Genau, und deswegen gab es halt einfach, ich glaube, sieben Monate oder so keine Rechnung von dieser Firma.
Excel ist scheiße.
Also das irgendwie...
Naja, es ist nicht unbedingt dafür gedacht, damit zu arbeiten.
Ja, das ist genau unsere Aussage.
Solche Dinge damit zu tun. Aber es funktioniert meistens...
Ich meine, es hat irgendwie Rundungsfehler drin, die mich schon zur Verzweiflung gebracht haben. Und es hat irgendwie Rechenfehler drin. Richtige, beschissene Rechenfehler. Entschuldigung, ich spiele nur im Radio. Aber es hat richtige Rechenfehler drin, die dazu führen, dass irgendwie Berechnungen schlicht und ergreifend falsch werden.
Das ist manchmal komisch, das stimmt. Aber man sollte das ja sowieso nachrechnen.
Wenn ich ein Computer benutze, will ich es nicht nachrechnen, damit ich davon ausgehe, dass es funktioniert. Ich meine, alles andere ist doch total hirnlässig.
Pavel, du sollst gegen Windows-Equatsch führen, wenn du das argumentierst.
Nein, das meine ich nicht.
Du meinst es voll ernst, dass man das nachrechnet?
Außerdem, ja, man kann außerdem den Spreadsheet dazu nehmen, um die Sache nachzurechnen. Dann nimmt man zwei oder drei verschiedene Arten, wie man das berechnet, und dann guckt man, ob man zu demselben ergeben wird.
Lassen wir uns mal kurz überlegen, was heutzutage eigentlich mit Exit passiert. Da gab es übrigens bei diesem Crangly dieses schöne Zitat, irgendwie das größte Problem, das PCs erzeugt haben, war, dass sie irgendwie 25-jährigen Harvard-MBAs irgendwie das Werkzeug in die Hand gegeben haben, loszugehen, irgendwie zu der Wirtschaft zu gehen, ihm ein paar gefälschte Daten in eine Spreadsheet-Tabelle reinzuhaken und ihn damit zu überzeugen, den Pensionsfonds zu plündern und irgendwie irgendwas ganz schrecklich Dummes zu tun. So, wenn wir uns mal überlegen, wofür Excel heutzutage verwendet wird, das ist in der Regel für Geld. So, irgendwie 98% aller Anwendungen, die mit Excel zu tun haben, haben mit Geld zu tun und irgendwie mit Plänen für irgendwie...
Na, haben nicht alle Berechnungen mit Geld zu tun über kurz oder lang?
Okay, Cashflow-Pläne, was auch immer, was man halt alles so machen muss, irgendwie, wenn man halt irgendwie so ein Unternehmen gründet, so macht man halt alles mit Excel. Und wenn sich da irgendwas verrechnet, so, dann möchte ich dieses Programm schlicht und ergreifend überhaupt nicht benutzen.
Na, man könnte ja sagen, es ist ja so einfach zu bedienen, was ich übrigens nicht finde.
Ja, aber vielleicht findet sich da jemand, es verrechnet sich nicht oft.
Das Einzige, was schlimmer ist, als eine falschgehende Uhr, sind zwei Uhren.
Also das ist wirklich, also ich muss wirklich sagen, Excel ist wirklich, also Word schlägt es noch um Längen, aber Excel ist schon ganz schön schlimm. Ich meine, Word ist tatsächlich ein genaues Programm, wo ich mich immer frage, was denken die sich dabei eigentlich? Man denkt irgendwie, wenn man so ein Textverarbeitungsprogramm hat, damit kann man jetzt zum Beispiel, sagen wir mal, ein Buch schreiben.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, wie Word entstanden ist?
Warte mal, ein Buch schreiben ist so ziemlich genau das Einzige, was man mit Word nicht kann, weil irgendwie jede Datei, die über 50 Seiten hat, ist in Word de facto unbenutzbar. Also da braucht man dann schon wieder irgendwie so viel Speicher, dass man denkt, man könnte sich gleich einen Mac kaufen.
Das ist nicht vom Speicher abhängig. Also ich hab irgendwie 256 Megabyte und da sollte man denken, mit Word kannst du da eine 20 Seiten Datei bearbeiten, das stimmt nicht. Also sobald du Bilder inkludest, zum Beispiel, kannst du in die Tonne hauen.
Es gibt aber viele Leute, die damit erfolgreich Bücher geschrieben haben.
Es ist wirklich nicht erfolgreich.
Nein, es gibt Leute, die damit schwerer Leiden geschrieben haben.
Genau, unter schweren Leiden.
Es gibt auch Leute, die in Tonschulen Berge besteigen. Das kann man tun, aber es ist nicht gut.
Aber die wenigsten Leute schreiben auch Bücher, muss man sagen.
Viele Leute schreiben ziemlich lange Berichte. Und eine Software, die es mir ermöglicht, ein Programm zu schreiben, das an beliebiger Stelle Schimpfworte einfügt. Und zwar genau so, dass diese Schimpfworte immer genau eingefügt werden, wenn die Datei speichere, aber beim Öffnen wieder rausgenommen werden. Und beim Drucken aber natürlich auch drin sind.
Du sprichst jetzt von den Makrovieren. Gut, dass nun irgendwelche Leute Rechner für Dinge missbrauchen, für die sie eigentlich nicht gedacht waren.
Da kommt die Criminal Energy Argumentation.
Moment, können wir kurz erläutern, wie Word entstanden ist. Word ist entstanden als Demoprogramm bei der Microsoft-Mouse. Da war ein Demoprogramm dabei, was zeigen sollte, wie man Software so schreibt, dass sie mit der Maus bedienbar ist. Denn die Maus auf dem PC zu verbreiten, war tatsächlich Leistung von Microsoft. Die man ihnen auch im Nachhinein darf man gar nicht übernehmen. Also das war eine Sache gut. Überhaupt ist die Hardware von Microsoft meistens tatsächlich benutzbar. Stimmt. Aber da war ein Demoprogramm dabei, was zufällig genauso aussah wie Word für DOS später. Wo man unten Menüs hatte, die konnte man mit der Pause und mit der Tastatur bedienen. Und daraus haben sie dann eine Textverarbeitung gemacht.
Wenn man darüber lässt, wie schlecht Word und Excel sind, dann fragen sich natürlich viele Leute, aber warum benutzen es dann alle, wenn es angeblich so schlecht ist?
Das Problem ist, dass die anderen genauso schlecht oder noch schlechter.
Das ist überhaupt nicht das Problem. Ich benutze, wenn ich auf dem PC Textverarbeitung mache, sondern uns da kein Frame Maker gibt, auf dem manch, da benutze ich meistens Star Office. Und Frame Maker ist eine Software, die für meine Begriffe die beste Textverarbeitung ist, die man sich so denken kann, weil sie irgendwie alle Funktionen bietet, die ein normaler Anwender braucht.
Also ich weiß ja nicht. Ich finde, wir sollen hier keinen Vodaflash mehr machen. Also man kann jede Software total demontieren, indem man jemanden, der findet, dass diese Software gut ist, ein Dokument gibt und ihm nur über die Schulter guckt. Man muss gar nichts tun, man muss keine Kommentare abgeben. Einfach nur zugucken, wie derjenige eine typische Aufgabe erledigt und dabei lautflucht.
Und bei jedem Programm, was ich bisher bis jetzt zu Test unterzogen habe, wird man feststellen, dass derjenige irgendwie größte Probleme hat bei einfachen Formatierungsaufgaben.
Und dann am Ende sagt, das ist aber sonst überhaupt nicht. Und das ist nur heute und das ist Vorführeffekt. Aber tatsächlich ist es so, dass man sich einfach daran gewöhnt hat, dass die Software heutzutage schlecht ist.
Und dann wollen wir mal drüber nachdenken.
Im Prinzip ist natürlich das Konzept von einzelner Software für alle möglichen Aufgaben vollkommen veraltet, das auf dem Computer. Weil es komplett das Schwachsinn ist. Warum muss ich einen Computer anschalten? Dann starte ich Photoshop, dann starte ich Word, dann starte ich Excel und dann starte ich noch ein, weiß ich nicht, Editor fürs Programmieren, um übertragen zu können.
Das musst du ja gar nicht machen. Nein, musst du nicht extra alles starten. Du kannst es aus Suspend zu Disk machen. Man kann es schon machen heute.
Das Konzept ist veraltet.
Im Prinzip wäre es sicherlich recht, wenn ich mir angucke, dass die Alternative zu Microsoft Office ist. Die zwar sagen, wir integrieren alle Applikationen, aber um den Preis, dass ich mir diesen PC nicht traue, um eine Homebanking Software zu installieren, weil darauf so viel Software ist, mit der man potenziell Mist bauen kann. Ich weiß nicht. Für meine Begriffe ist diese ganze Office-Schiene und vor allen Dingen die Problematik, dass in vielen Firmen dieses Programm mittlerweile so standardisiert ist, dass man de facto gezwungen ist, diese Software auf seinem Rechner installiert zu haben.
Word wird zum Beispiel dadurch erzwungen, dass man, wenn man ISO-Dokumente schreiben will, ISO ist die internationale Standardorganisation, die wichtigste Organisation der Welt, wenn es um technische Standards geht, wenn man da einen Proposal abgeben will, einen Standard unterbreiten will oder auch nur einen Kommentar abgeben will, dann muss man das als Word-Dokument machen. Das heißt, die Welt ist unterwandert. Die NATO, eine komplette NT-Infrastruktur, da kommen Briefe als Word-Attachments.
Also die deutsche Wirtschaft wird heutzutage durchbetrieben, dass per E-Mail Word-Dateien verschickt werden. Das ist tatsächlich die Betriebsgrundlage der Wirtschaft in praktisch allen westlichen Ländern. Die Makrovieren sind einfach mal ein exzellentes Beispiel dafür, wie man auf der Basis solcher Monokultur richtig Schaden anrichten kann. Ich find's eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Ein Satz noch mal dazu, kurz, Makrovieren. Makros kann man in den meisten Microsoft-Programmen mit mir dranhängen. Das sind aber Programme.
Die werden halt ausgeführt, sobald diese Datei geöffnet wird.
Also man wird gefragt.
Nicht zu zwingend. Man kann ja auch so designen, dass man... Also natürlich muss man dazu kriminelle Energie erörten. Wenn die typische Microsoft-Argumentation wie so ihre Software denn doch nicht schlecht ist, lautet ja, naja, dazu muss man aber schon ganz schön böswillig sein.
Nicht nur böswillig. Zum Beispiel bei den Makros poppt halt schön ein Dialog hoch. Normalerweise, wo man dann gefragt wird. Gut, es mag Ausnahmen geben.
Nein, was heißt es mag Ausnahmen geben? Es gibt zum Beispiel Dokument Templates. Also, wie heißen die auf Deutsch? Schablonen, Dokumentenvorlagen. Wenn man da Makros drin hat, wird man nicht gefragt, weil Microsoft irgendwie vergessen hat. Und wenn man sie darauf anspricht, was mehrfach passiert ist, dann sagen sie, ja, aber dazu muss man extra wieder energieren. Erstens das und zum Zweiten, aber die Makros sind doch normalerweise in Invert-Dateien. Also Microsoft versagt schlicht auf ganzer Bandbreite. Kann man nicht anders formulieren.
Wo sie noch versagen und wo sie nicht versagen, gibt's nach dem Fritz-Konzern irgendwo. Mehr Chaosradio gleich nach dem hier.
Wenn Fritz in Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Reise, die Bundesregierung will Israel und die Palästinenser bei ihrem Friedensprozess unterstützen. Das sagte aus Minister Fischer bei getrennten Treffen mit der israelischen Regierung und Palästinenser Präsident Arafat zu. Unterstützung, die notleidende Bevölkerung im Kosovo erhält rund 3, 7 Milliarden Mark internationale Finlands Hilfe für den Wiederaufbau. Darauf verständigten sich Vertreter von über 100 Staaten und Organisationen auf der ersten sogenannten Geberkonferenz in Brüssel. Boat People, die italienische Küstenwache, hat heute ein Schiff mit fast 890 Roma-Flüchtlingen aus dem Kosovo aufgebracht. Es wurde rund 60 Seemalen vor der Küste entdeckt und in den süditalienischen Hafen Brindisi geschleppt. Ermittlung bei der Suche nach dem Gewaltverbrecher Dieter Zurwimme hofft die Polizei auf einen Fahndungserfolg im Raum Hannover. Am westlichen Stadtrand werden strenge Straßenkontrollen durchgeführt. Ein jeder glaubt, Zurwimme vergangene Nacht bei Hannover gesehen zu haben. Fußball der Hamburger SV erreichte im Halbfinale-Hinspiel um den Ui-Cup beim türkischen Meister Trabzon-Score. Ein 2 zu 2. 1 zu 1 trennte sich der MSV Duisburg vom französischen Vertreter SC Montpellier. Nachts klar bis 9 Grad, morgen wieder sommerlich bis 28 Grad.
Verkehr.
Es liegen keine Meldungen vor.
Nicole Marquardt mit dem Fritz ist kurz ein Vor.
Fritz präsentiert den Höhepunkt der Skatesaison 99. Die achte City-Nacht Berlin. Die achte City-Nacht Berlin. Samstag, 7.
August von 10 bis 23 Uhr an der Gedächtniskirche.
Ein Paradies fürs Skater.
Wie immer mit Fritz.
Weiter geht's mit dem Fritz Chaos Radio. Und erstmal ein bisschen Musik nochmal für den Einschuss in Neubauten. Sonnenbarke. Neues von den Neubauten. Ihr hört Chaos Radio, Computer Blumen bei Fritz. Das Thema lautet Microsoft. Bisher war es eher ein Referat. Aber ihr kommt gleich dazu. Dann können wir vielleicht gemeinsam ablästern oder ich hab eine Menge. Ich weiß, ich kriege oft öfter mal E-Mails von Hörern. Ich wollte gerade sagen und Hörerinnen, aber es stimmt ja überhaupt nicht. Von Hörern, die irgendwie sagen, was lästert ihr immer über Microsoft? Ist doch geil. Das liegt meistens daran, dass die Leute selber noch nichts anderes benutzt haben oder ihr noch nicht ganz klar ist. Ich benutze ziemlich lange schon beides und auch verschiedene andere Systeme. Ich habe auch mit US2 meine Erfahrung und mit Linux und so weiter. Und Windows ist einfach ein scheiß Betriebssystem zum Arbeiten.
Sollen wir vielleicht mal klarstellen, weil das im Chat immer ganz gern gefragt wird. Wir sind nicht der Meinung, dass keiner Windows benutzen sollte. Wir finden überhaupt nicht, dass ihr uns jetzt hier glauben sollt, sondern wir finden, dass ihr euch selber mit eurer Technik auseinandersetzen solltet. Und wenn ihr nicht selber aus eigenem Antrieb von Windows weggeht, dann seid ihr auch nicht wirklich weggegangen, weil irgendwelche Leute hinterher laufen. Das ist kein Hacken. Das qualifiziert einen zu gar nichts. Also ihr solltet euch genügend Alternativen anschauen und dann die für euch wichtigste und beste wählen. Wenn das Windows ist, was meines Erachtens sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, dann sollt ihr Windows benutzen. Also da haben wir nichts dagegen.
Also mein Problem irgendwie, was ich gerade habe, ist irgendwie, dass Linux mittlerweile Mainstream ist. Und deswegen gehöre ich auch auf Linux zu supporten, weil irgendwie empfehle ich niemanden mehr, sich Linux zu installieren, weil irgendwie hinterher kommen die Leute doch bloß anderen, stellen dumme Fragen.
Für die meisten Zwecke ist Windows einfach genau das Richtige.
Also meine persönliche Empfehlung an alle Leute, die mich fragen, ob sie sich und was sie sich für einen Computer kaufen sollen, ist immer, kauft ihr einen Mac? Weil letzten Endes hat mich noch nie, wirklich noch nie jemand angerufen, dem ich gesagt habe, kauft ihr einen Mac, der mich mit Problemen belästigt.
Dafür hast du mich angerufen mit Problemen belästigen.
Als ich irgendwie mal wieder mit Lidl spielen musste.
Du hast mich nicht mit Mac OS mit Problemen belästigt, sondern mit deinem Pgp-Programm.
Na komm, bei deinem Duma-Beller, irgendwie beschissene Pgp-Mimes raus tut egal.
Also ich hab die Erfahrung gemacht, dass ich schon von Leuten bin, denen ich einen Mac empfohlen hab, angerufen worden, aber höchstens drei Wochen lang. Also da kamen so die ersten Fragen, wie mach ich dies, wie mach ich das. Also wenn sie noch nie mit dem Computer zu tun hatten, vielleicht klicken sie sofort auch gleich Internet installiert, das ist ja inzwischen auch noch einfacher geworden.
Also man kann sagen, der größte Fehler, den Leute machen können mit Computern, ist nicht irgendwie Zeitungen kaufen, wo drin steht, zum Tunen müssen sie dieses und jenes tun. Denn der Mac ist nicht inhärent user-sicher oder irgendwie einfacher zu bedienen, sondern beim PC gibt es halt 10 Milliarden PC-Schrauben und Drehzeitungen und da steht drin auf Seite 15, Windows ist schneller oder Windows ist stabiler, wenn sie dieses Programm und da rumklicken und wenn die Leute das tun, geht es eben kaputt. Also wenn man Windows in der Sekretierung installiert und die einfach nicht erklärt, wie man da was anderes tut als Word starten, dann funktioniert das normalerweise auch abgesehen. Das Word eben ab und zu abstürzt, aber das ist zu viel, wenn man das mit dem Wohnpost startet. Ja, natürlich, aber es ist nicht so, dass Windows einfach inhärent unstabil wäre. Nur wenn du die Leute eben klicken lässt und auch bei Mac, ich kenne durchaus Leute, die sich Mac installiert haben und die haben dann Netzgap in den Systemfolder gedragged, weil System klingt wichtig und Netzgap ist wichtig und dann gibt es eben Probleme. Man kann auch mit Mac OS natürlich Sachen kaputt machen.
Das ist richtig.
Aber den Leuten neigen die da nicht dazu. Die Leute neigen auch bei Windows eigentlich nicht dazu. Es steht halt in Zeitungen, da hat es ja Wetterbücher drin.
Bei Windows versuchen sie halt zum Beispiel eine Soundcard zu installieren und es ist meistens in der Regel das Ende dieses Systems.
Das ist Legende.
Nein, das ist keine Legende.
Vor einem halben Jahr habe ich ohne Probleme Windows 98 installiert. Du hast ja ein vorkonfiguriertes System und kaufte eine Soundcard drin. Das hat vier Wochen gelaufen, bis es das erste Mal abgestürzt war. Ich habe alle möglichen Karten reingesteckt, Ethernet, TV-Karten reinstecken, Körper, was noch, alle möglichen Kramen. Das hat ohne Probleme funktioniert. Es laufen alle Spiele drauf. Alles, was man im Netz findet, gibt es auf jeden Fall auch für Windows.
Ich halte es einfach für möglich.
Nein, das ist eine selektive Wahrnehmung.
Das ist nicht mal eine selektive Wahrnehmung. Das letzte Mal, als ich eine Soundcard und ein PC installiert habe, hat es mich eine halbe Tag gekostet.
Das liegt an deinem schlechten Karma.
Nein, bis dieses Dumme enthehme wieder lief. Ich habe deinen Butter drauf gestört und sogar meine Kristallkugel daneben liegt.
Der einzige, der Computer gegenüber schlechtes Karma hat, bin ich, da lege ich Wert drauf. Wenn ich bei Frank hinterstehe und er mir irgendwas zeigen will, das läuft mit Sicherheit nicht.
Du wolltest noch was erzählen über deine Windows-Experiments.
Ich wollte ja genau, ich wollte noch mehrere Sachen erzählen. Also ein Spruch, der sich bewahrheitet hat, den ich an dieser Stelle auch mal hier auf Radio sagen könnte, dass jeder hat das Betriebssystem, was er verdient hat. Also wenn jemandem Windows zufrieden ist, dann ist es auch gut. Also was ich erzählen wollte, ich habe...
Und offenbar sind die meisten damit zufrieden.
Die Leute sind nicht zufrieden, aber sie wissen ja nicht, was sie sonst machen sollen. Also die Leute sind auch mit Linux normalerweise nicht zufrieden. Das ist ja auch gut so, wenn die Leute alle zufrieden wären, das wäre langweilig. Also was ich erzählen wollte...
Die Masse entscheidet einfach nicht, Punkt. Weil die Masse ist blöd, tut mir echt leid.
1000 Fliegen...
Einschaltquoten haben auch nicht die Sendung, also das ist ein Kulturprozent, das ist wahr.
Na ja, Kultur ist vielleicht auch nicht so unscheinend. Also das ist eben auch subjektiv. Und letztendlich, wenn euch euer System gefällt, dann ist gut.
Letztendlich kommt es darauf an, seine Arbeit getan zu kriegen.
Ja, aber jetzt lass mich mal kurz meine Historie zeigen. Also ich hab mein Rechner umgebaut, hab mir dann eine neue Grafikkarte eingebaut, weil irgendwie ist toll und wunderbar. Und dann hab ich unter anderem auch die Prozessoren ausgetauscht. Und so war ein größerer Umbau, jedenfalls als dann endlich die Hardware soweit zusammengestöpselt war und die Lüfter alle angeschlossen waren, hab ich natürlich erstmal Linux gebootet, weil das ist mein Hauptsystem. Und da hab ich dann den Kern ein bisschen modifiziert, neueren Treiber reingetan für meine Grafikkarte, damit ich eine grafische Konsole hab. Dann hab ich mir einen passenden X-Server gesorgt. Das hat insgesamt fünf Minuten gedauert, weil das war halt eine gute Internetanbindung. Also so vom Aufwandtippen her vielleicht eine Minute. Und dann lief Linux mit der neuen Grafikkarte, den neuen Prozessoren. Und dann hab ich Windows gebootet. Und es hat irgendwie sieben Stunden gedauert, weil Windows so einfach Probleme hat, die man nicht los wird. Wie zum Beispiel, wenn man eine Grafikkarte aus dem Device-Manager entfernt und Windows nicht im Safe Mode bootet, dann sagt Windows beim nächsten Booten VGA detected, denkt drei Sekunden nach und guckt dann in seinen Konfigurationsdateien nach, wo drin steht, was vorher installiert war, und installiert den Treiber einfach wieder. Es gibt einfach so zwei, drei Sachen, die sind einfach grundlegend schlecht.
Aber einen Linux-Könnel zu backen, ist auch nichts für jeder, man will halt...
Nein, den Linux-Könnel musst du nicht anfassen, um die Grafikkarte zu benutzen. Das war diese spezielle Konsole, die ich haben wollte. Das ist nicht essenzielle Funktionalität sozusagen. Also den X-Tabler auspacken kann jeder. Und ich hab nun nicht mal irgendwie ein System, wo du einfach ein grafisches Tool benutzt, um zu sagen... Ich mein, gut, man kann immer argumentieren, wenn man seinen Rechner wirklich gut kennt, dann ist es immer kein Problem. Aber letztendlich ist es so, dass man... Also meine Hauptbeschwerde bei Windows ist einfach, wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert, wird es einem auch nicht gesagt, was nicht funktioniert und warum es nicht funktioniert. Also bei mir ist es zum Beispiel so, dass der SCSI-Triver zwar die neueste Version ist, aber wenn ich da...
Was machst du mit deinem Computer? Darfst du dich mal unterbrechen, außer basteln?
Na basteln ist einfach wichtig für mich, weil ich mach das beruflich und ich bin unter anderem dafür bezahlt, dass ich Leuten helfen kann. Und dann heißt es nicht, ich muss auf YouTube basteln.
Aber den Beruf hättest du zum Beispiel gar nicht, wenn es Windows nicht gäbe.
Nein, ich helfe nicht nur Windows-Leute im Gegenteil. Windows ist eher so Not-Brotenschaffung.
Also ich finde, das hängt schwer davon ab, was du mit deinem Computer machen willst.
Na klar, sicher. Nein, aber es ging jetzt einfach nur ein Fallbeispiel. Also unter anderem, warum ich hier für die Sendung sozusagen...
Also eines der Dinge, die mich an PCs immer wieder anüdet, ist, dass man sie einschaltet und sie haben erstmal keinen Sound.
Stimmt doch gar nicht. Mein Laptop hat von vornherein Sound gehabt.
Naja, also mein Mac macht irgendwie Böng, wenn ich ihn einschalte. Das hat bisher jeder Mac gemacht, den ich hatte. Mein PC...
Das ist übrigens echt scheiße.
Auf dem Camp zum Beispiel oder beim letzten Kongress, das ist echt scheiße, wenn du PC anstellst und du machst... Und dieser Windows-Sound, weißt du, so ein großer Raum mit tausend Leuten und ihren Rechnern und es macht ständig aus irgendeiner...
Nein, warum ich hinauswolle ist eigentlich, dass man in diesen PCs erst mal IR-Qs konfigurieren muss.
Du warst lang nicht mehr dabei.
Also ich hab auch ein PC mit Plug & Play.
Hey, man muss auch bei Mac ir-Qs konfigurieren.
Und ich hab da irgendwie eine PCI-Soundkarte reingesteckt, weil ich dachte irgendwie, jetzt muss doch endlich mal dieses Problem beroben werden. Und ich wollte dann endlich mal nach mehreren Jahren endlich Sound in meinem PC haben und hab mir eine PCI-Soundkarte gekauft und hab die halt da reingesteckt und angeschaltet. Die hatte ich auch erkannt und dann hat er den Treiber installiert und dann hat er neu gebootet und dann hat er gemeint, der Treiber wäre nicht installiert. Dann hab ich den Treiber nochmal installiert und dann hat er gebootet und gemeint, der Treiber wäre nicht installiert.
Das ist eine wunderbare, sowas nennt man anekdotische Evidenz dafür, dass Windows scheiße ist. Also die schönste Sache, die mir da in letzter Zeit begegnet ist, war eine Sendung vom WDR Computer Club, eigentlich eine eher reaktionäre Sendung, die man eigentlich nur so wegen dem Spaß, wie man sich mal anguckt, abläuft.
Die jetzt tatsächlich auch einen iMac dastehen haben.
Ja, genau. Also die Sendung, wo sie den iMac dahin getan haben, da haben sie einfach USB demonstrieren wollen. USB wird ja gerade vermarktet, mit der Begründung, dass Windows 98 USB-Support hat. Dann haben sie halt irgendeine ISDN-Komponente oder sowas da angeschlossen, und es funktionierte überhaupt nicht. Also Windows hat die Ad detected und hat gesagt, Treiber einlegen, haben den Treiber eingelegt, mussten booten. Da hat man sich auch gewöhnt dran heutzutage. Haben gebootet, Windows hat es wieder detected, sie haben wieder den Treiber eingeliehen, es ging so ein paar Minuten. Dann meinten sie, ja, also so geht das ja nun nicht, und jetzt zeigen wir ihnen mal, wie das gehen kann, haben das in den iMac reingestöpft und es lief so out of the box. Also Windows 98, es gibt sicher Leute, die das so richtig aus dem FF beherrschen, das bestreite ich ja gar nicht, der Programmierer von dem System oder die Programmierer von dem USB-System kriegen das bestimmt auch zu laufen, aber normale Leute eben nicht, oder nur zufällig. Das ist einfach überhaupt irgendwie heraufgestellt.
Ja, also gerade was irgendwie Hardware-Komponenten betrifft, irgendwie...
Also es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund, USB zu benutzen, oder?
Ich meine, nur ein Scanner kaufe stehe ich heute vor, also die kaufe ich mir Scazi oder USB. Ich kaufe mir natürlich Scazi, weil ich einen Mac habe. Aber irgendwie, wenn ich einen PC hätte, würde ich mir irgendwie einen USB-Scanner kaufen. Weil, denke ich, mir einfach ranstecken und geht.
Ja, aber dann wartet man noch ein Jahr, dann funktioniert das auch. Und bis dahin kauft man halt kein USB.
Also ich bin bisher relativ beeindruckt von USB bisher.
Ja, bisher funktioniert das gut, ranstecken und geht.
Scanner ist genau das Stichwort. Scanner werden immer billiger, also brauchen wir uns nicht drüber unterhalten. Der erste, den ich irgendwann mal gekauft habe, hat 4500 Marke gekostet. Der hatte nicht halb die Auflösung wie der, den ich jetzt für 280 gekauft habe.
Naja, aber die Auflösung von heute ist auch Interpolation und nicht wirklich Auflösung.
Die physikalische Auflösung ist schon modisch.
Die steht ja gar nicht mehr dran.
Bis 600 kriegst du schon echt...
Ja, aber ich mein, guck dir mal irgendwie, ich war gestern, ich bin jetzt, wie gesagt, in dem Rechner aufgerufen, jetzt ist ja noch eine kurze Zeit mit. Da steht überall 1440 mal 1440.
Ja, das ist interpoliert. Aber das steht nicht auf dem Scanner.
Nein, gut, also Scanner hab ich ja nicht gesehen.
Scheißegal, bis 600 kriegst du irgendwie normal und so ist auch okay. Und USB, also das Gase ist jetzt auch kein Problem, du machst einmal den Treiber, irgendwie geht auch, aber USB steckst rein und geht. Das ist schon erstaunlich. Außerdem mag ich die Stecker.
Auf dem Mac ist was anderes, da funktioniert das auch. Dafür kann man halt nicht alles anschließen.
Also um es mal kurz zusammenzufassen, man hat in Macs einen Computer, den man braucht, wenn man richtige Arbeit machen will und wenn man programmieren will, dann muss man sich halt einen PC kaufen. Aber neulich, da war ich echt erstaunt, da habe ich mir mal dieses Real Basic installiert.
Super.
Und da kam plötzlich so ein PC-Feeling auf an diesem Macintosh. Da konnte man plötzlich programmieren, die Kisten zum Abschleißen bringen.
Und die neue Version kann sogar Windows Programme erstellen.
Also, dass ich meine, diese Vorstellung, auf einer Plattform ohne Speicherschutz zu entwickeln, für eine andere Plattform ohne Speicherschutz, ich meine, was geht denn euch vor, Leute?
Nimmt doch mal die richtige Plattform.
Hier kommt übrigens im Chat eine wunderbare Anmerkung. Also bei Mac USB mal steckt rein, es läuft. Bei Windows, man steckt rein und kriegt ein Bluescreen.
Das ist natürlich genau richtig.
Du kriegst ein was?
Aber es muss jetzt nicht mehr ein Bluescreen sein. Es gibt ja jetzt Tools, mit denen man den Bluescreen...
Wenn man weiß, wo man es einstellen kann.
Dann kann man die Farbe verändern.
Ich meine, wir können auch, wenn wir schon am Lästern sind, alleine Installationen von irgendwasen, wobei die ja bei Mac jetzt auch diese ganzen Abfragen vorher haben, aber Setup starten von irgendeinem Programm auf Windows, ist immer wieder ein Spaß, finde ich.
Und zu echt, die Setup-Tools, ich meine, man bockt das aus, und dann ist gut. Also ich verstehe gar nicht, was die Leute da drum mitstecken.
Das Problem ist halt, man muss halt irgendwie noch 1000 Dateile, 27 Subverzeichnisse, System und Inni und...
Hab ich überhaupt kein Problem mit Unterwindows, Unterlinix. Jetzt machst du aus und es läuft, fertig.
Nicht noch DLS installieren.
Wenn wir jetzt schon so viele Geschichten haben von uns hier, dann würde ich so sagen, wir machen mal die Telefonleitung auf und ihr könnt uns mal erzählen.
Die schlimmsten Erfahrungen. Wir wollen jetzt von euch hören, was die schlimmsten und peinlichsten Momente waren. Am besten möchten wir es, Leute haben die Rechenzentren für große Firmen verwalten und eines Nachts aus dem Bett gerufen wurden, aus dem Urlaub anreisen mussten, überhaupt die tollsten Stories jetzt hier live, wenn ihr noch nicht eingeschlafen seid.
Die Tritts-Podline ist geschaltet.
0331 für Poxderm, 7097110.
Haben wir da schon jemanden? Wer ist denn da?
Ja, hallo, hier ist der KAC-Kid. Ja, mein Problem ist immer mit Windows und dem ganzen, naja, ich würde nicht sagen, Mist, man ist ja heutzutage richtig drauf angewiesen. Weil ich programmiere selber, wir haben so Fehleranalyse, Fehlerauswertungen von speziellen, naja, einer Reparaturfirma bei der Instandhaltung. Da programmiere ich gerade unter DOS, weil jetzt überall auf den Rechnern, die da vorhanden sind, läuft so ein Programm. Und nun möchte ich natürlich, dass das auch bei den Juro dann da oben lesbar ist und bin dabei, das in Excel zu konvertieren. Also die Datensätze, die ich jetzt so erstelle mit diesen Fehlern, möchte ich gerne in der Excel-Datei haben. Das Problem ist, Excel findet man nirgendwo ohne Beschreibung, wie das aufgebaut ist. Also da fängt es schon mal an.
Na, das ist inzwischen dokumentiert. Also es ist ein Standard, der über 100 Seiten geht. Ist nicht, will man nicht wirklich haben.
Wenn ich da eine einfache zweidimensionale Tabelle exportiere in Excel, dann muss ich erstmal die 100 Seiten lesen, oder wie?
Na Excel ist doch nicht dafür da einfache Tabellen zu machen, Excel ist dafür da Rechnungen zu schreiben.
Genau, Rechnungen zu schreiben und irgendwie...
Nein, mach eine HTML-Seite, dann können das alle sehen, und dann können das auch Leute sehen, die nicht Microsoft-Systeme benutzen.
Ja, sicherlich, plus HTML ist ja nun bei uns im Büro nicht so.
Na, wieso ist das bei euch im Büro nicht so? Ich mein, Excel installieren ist genauso schwierig wie Netscape zu installieren.
Ja, aber da hat man natürlich ein anderes Problem. Da gibt es einfach eine Formstruktur, da kann man nicht sagen, pass mal auf Leute ab, jetzt kommt auf jeden Rechner Netscape oder Explorer oder was auch immer.
Nein, aber im Moment könnt ihr die Daten gar nicht lesen und sie überlegen gerade, ob sie übernächseln.
Ja doch, Moment, Moment, ich hab das jetzt, ich hab das auch gefunden und Excel gibt es eine Funktion, wo man das in SLK-Dateien, Symbol Link, importieren kann. Also Excel kann SLK importieren und das ist, was vorhin schon mal gesagt wurde, dieser ISO-Standard. Also ich glaube, diese großen Pakete, die sind verpflichtet, international auch Normen zu lesen.
Aha, überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe mir diese Dateiaufbau mal angeguckt und festgestellt, es ist eine reine Textdatei und war natürlich sehr leicht zu durchschauen. Also die Formatierung von Tabellen und so weiter, wie das dann aufgebaut ist. Also relativ einfaches Tabellenformat, was Excel dann auch lesen kann.
Was hast du hingekriegt soweit?
Nun lesen die keine Excel-Tabelle, sondern eben eine SLK-Datei. Und die sieht man dann in Excel auch.
Also das reicht ja eigentlich.
Kannst du einfach formatierten Text nehmen. Aber das war jetzt nicht wirklich eine schlechte oder so beeindruckende, sondern einfach eine tragweite unglaubliche Computer-Story. Also ist ja mal so was richtig Peinliches passiert. Was wär jetzt am besten ohne Nennung deines Namens hier auch versprechen, nicht weiter zu erzählen?
Also bisher kommst du im Großen und Ganzen klar. Dann haben wir noch einen schönen Abend. Und wen haben wir jetzt hier? Niemand mehr.
Also ich hab damals ein 388 hier. Und Windows 3, 3.1, ja. Und also spielen hat alles wunderbar geklappt. Jedes Spiel lief. Und wie es dann mal darum ging, die Hausarbeit drauf zu schreiben, ist in jedem Satz abgestürzt. Ja, und dann noch hin und her probiert, also um das noch zum lofen zu kriegen. Und ja, im Endeffekt habe ich dann die Hausarbeit auf der Schreibmaschine geblieben.
Das ist allerdings eine schön peinliche Geschichte. Was hast du mit was für einem Programm versucht, da zu schreiben? Hast du den Eindruck, dass durch die ganzen Spiele, die du da drauf hattest, Word vielleicht nicht mehr funktioniert hat?
Wie?
Hattest du den Eindruck, dass dadurch, dass du da mehrere Spiele drauf installiert hattest, dass deswegen deine Textverarbeitung nicht mehr so funktioniert hat, wie sie sollte?
Nee, die Spiele waren ja alles noch im DOS, die habe ich alles im DOS gestapelt. Und Windows lief eigentlich auch so, aber sobald ich halt so getippt habe, war weg. Also mit den Spielen hatte ich eigentlich nicht den Eindruck, dass es daran liegt.
Aber zurück auf die Schreibmaschine, finde ich eine ganz hübsche Geschichte.
Ich danke dir.
Es gab ja diese großartige IBM-Werbung, da mal so auf einer Doppelseite einfach nur das Wort Schreibmaschine stand, mitte die Buchstaben IBM. Ganz großartig. Ich glaube, dass man Computer noch so vermarkten konnte.
Nein, es ging nicht darum, sondern es ging darum, dass man im BIOS IBM den String nicht stehen haben durfte, weil das eine Markenschutz verrechnet hat. Also ein Problem von Markennamen, der ist halt geschützt.
Nein, es ging darum, Computer zu vermarkten.
Nein, nicht nur das. Es gab tatsächlich so eine Story, da ging es darum, dass es im BIOS IBM stehen musste, weil Programme danach gesucht haben.
Aber es ging bei der Anzeige nicht ums BIOS.
Ja, aber das ist gemein. Lass mich doch mal ausregen. Also es gab jedenfalls BIOS, die Schreibmaschine da stehen hatten, damit irgendwie andere Programme, die gucken wollten, ob das ein IBM BIOS ist, da IBM gefunden haben. Ohne, dass du es reingeschrieben hast. Also es gibt da Überschneidungen. Offensichtlich. Okay.
Hi, wer ist denn da?
Hallo Matthias.
Ich wollte erst mal sagen, für alle, die jetzt irgendwie meinen, Winders stürzen jetzt zu oft ab, will ich nicht, wäre die ultimative Alternative. Erst mal zwei Partitionen machen, dann auf einen Linie drauf andere Winders verhalten, damit, falls mal unter dem Linie drauf nicht klappen sollte, im Einzelfall, man irgendwie nochmal auf das alte Winders zurückgreifen kann.
Das ist ein guter Tipp. Du brauchst natürlich eine große Festplatte, ne? Also relativ.
Das kostet mir heute nichts mehr.
Also heutzutage, ich hab im Oktober meinen Rechner gekauft, da waren zehn Gigabit drin, das hat mir erst mal gereicht.
Wie alt bist du, Marius?
13.
Was kriegst du an Taschengeld?
30 Mark im Monat.
Den hast du dann aber nicht selber bezahlt, den Rechner.
Nee, ich bin Hälfte, mein Bruder die Hälfte, aber heute hab ich mir auch einen neuen geholt, also von ein paar Tagen, aber...
Von 30 Mark im Monat?
Na, Rechner sind echt billig geworden, ne?
Na ja, ich mein, das gibt doch die Routen für VM-Ware, ne? Na ja, aber damit kann man wenigstens irgendwie das System gut isolieren.
Sag mal, du bist 13 und partitionierst deine Festplatten und installierst Linux und Windows und so?
Sieh ich da neid in deinen Augen?
Ja, siehst du neid in meinen Augen, weil ich es tatsächlich immer noch nicht geschafft hab, mit dem Monitor, den ich hab, auf dem einen PC, wo ich Linux installiert hab, dass der eine vernünftige Auflösung macht, der bleibt immer bei 640x480.
Naja, noch mal vor immer, man kann es auch mit einem Trick irgendwie, diese Registrierdauer, etwas verlängern bis zum Jahr 2079 oder so, aber hier.
Das hat 13 Jahre gebrochen.
Was würdet ihr da nicht tun? Das können wir doch hier auf dem Radio nicht den Leuten empfehlen.
Kommst du zum Camp?
Zum Camp noch ne Frage an Frank. Du meintest, man sollte nicht möglichst zu früh kommen. Ich hab mir jetzt erstmal mein Reisezahn so auf Freitag, Samstag gesteckt. Gibt's da schon Toiletten?
Gucken wir auf den Web-Server. Da gibt's einen Feature-Variability-Chart, wo die jeweiligen Infrastrukturkomponenten drin sind, die zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon verfügbar sind. Ich glaube, die Klos kommen am Montag. Gucken wir auf dieses Chart. Das findest du vom Server relativ einfach. Da siehst du, wann was...
Hab ich mir schon angeschaut. Das war im 2. August. Weiter vorher gab's nichts. Bei der Registrierung konnte man angeben, 30. Juli, was mich ziemlich verwirrt hat.
Das ist zum Ausbauen.
Das war ein Fehler. Dieser 30. Juli, da fahren wir halt dahin. Guck mal, dass wir die Pferde von der Wiese scheuchen. Und zu sehen, dass die Badestelle einigermaßen zugänglich ist. Da ist noch nichts vorhanden, was irgendwie aussieht. Wenn du damit klarkommst, dass du auf einer Wiese mit nichts als vielleicht ein paar Pferden campen kannst, dann ist es okay. Aber ansonsten mehr wird da noch nicht sein. Und tatsächlich der richtige Aufbau mit Infrastruktur und so weiter beginnt halt am Montag, wo dann tatsächlich die schweren Sachen zu schleppen sind und so. Und Internet und ähnliche Dinge wird es dann eher so Dienstag, Mittwoch geben, wo wir dann halt tatsächlich schon anfangen können, ein Netzwerk aufzubauen und Strom zu legen und solche Geschichten. Das heißt also, guck dir das nochmal genau an.
Und ich denke also vor Dienstag zu kommen bringt nicht wirklich viel.
Wir sollten vielleicht noch mal ein, zwei Sachen zum Camp sagen, weil viele Leute haben uns gefragt, 150 Mark ist ja eine ganz schöne Stange Geld für so drei Tage auf der Wiese. Es ist halt leider so, dass diese Infrastruktur, die wir dahinstellen, halt irgendwie richtig viel Geld kostet. Also wir haben diese 150 Mark ehrlicherweise festgelegt, bevor wir wussten, was die ganze Angelegenheit ungefähr kosten würde. Das heißt, die sind irgendwie an einem fröhlichen Nachmittag entstanden, wo wir uns dachten, wir würden den Leute maximal ausgeben. Und wie sich denn herausgestellt hat, wenn wir irgendwie das, was es tatsächlich kostet, irgendwie direkt umlegen würden, dann wäre der Preis ungefähr doppelt so hoch. Wir haben halt zum Glück ein paar Sponsoren, die es uns ermöglichen, die Sache eben gerade so einigermaßen mit diesen 150 Mark zu finanzieren. Naja, die haben auch eine Marke zugetan, aber es ist halt so, dass wir da tatsächlich auch eine ziemliche Last zu stellen haben.
Also vielleicht zur Größenordnung. Da waren glaube ich selber alle dann ein bisschen überrascht. Also es wird alleine mindestens 1 Megawatt an elektrischer Energie benötigt für die Zeit des Camps. Also 1000 kW, die dann aus drei bis vier Generatoren gespeist werden, was so allein dann, naja, als ca. 20 bis 30 Tonnen Diesel bedeuten wird, die da für die Rechner verblasen werden. Das wird außerdem, glaube ich...
Also die genauen Details sind halt irgendwie nicht unbedingt verbreitungsfähig, aber es ist schon so, dass wir hinterher sicherlich sagen werden, was die ganze Sache kostet hat, und wir sind froh, wenn wir da gerade so rauskommen, dass wir dabei Gewinn machen, erwarten wir eigentlich überhaupt nicht. Also, ja, dann sagen wir mal, die Stromkosten sind ganz großartig. Also ich kann es mal kurz sagen, die Stromkosten sind fast 80.000 Mark, die es alleine kostet, diese Generatoren hinzustellen und die Kabel da überall auf dieses Feld zu legen. Also es ist schon so, dass das eine ziemliche Dimension ist.
Und ohne die Sponsoren wäre der Preis schätzungsweise bei dem Markt dreimal zu hoch.
Mindestens. Und deswegen auch die Sache, dass es deswegen unter anderem keine Tageskarten geben wird. Außerdem ist es sowieso nicht zu empfehlen, nur für einen Tag zu kommen, weil die Veranstaltungen beginnen erst wirklich etwa gegen Mittag. Und am interessantesten wird so sicher die Zeit zwischen 10 und 3 Uhr nachts potentiell werden. Und dann will man doch eigentlich auch nicht wieder wegfahren. Das heißt, man sollte wenigstens eine Übernachtung einplanen. Und ja, dann denke ich, sind die 150 Mark auch durchaus gerechtfertigt.
Wir haben ein Workshopprogramm, das an den drei Tagen stattfindet. Also Freitags, Samstags, Sonntag. Das jeweils um 12 Uhr mittags startet. Und der letzte Workshop wird dann wahrscheinlich jeweils gegen 22 bzw. 24 Uhr stattfinden. Das heißt, wir haben dieses Mal, im Gegensatz zum Kongress, ein hekka-tagesablaufs-kompatibles Workshopprogramm, wo die interessanten Sachen auch ein bisschen mehr in die Abendstunden gelagert werden, weil da die Leute doch in der Regel etwas aktiver und hunterer sind. Also wir haben ein extrem hochkarätiges Programm. Wir haben ziemlich viele Leute aus Amerika, aus Großbritannien, die interessante Workshops halten. Ich hoffe, dass wir morgen dazu kommen, das Workshopprogramm zu publishen auf dem Web-Server. Jedenfalls nach dem, was es da so gibt, würde man für diese Referenten auf einer kommerziellen Veranstaltung das Zehnfache zahlen.
Ganz abgesehen davon von den 35 Megabit Ethernet, die das haben wird, und wahrscheinlich eines der größten lokalen Netze, die so im Augenblick betrieben werden. Es wird allein 1100 Megabit Ports geben, ungefähr geswitchte. Und im Augenblick bei den Voranmeldungen liegt also die Rechner zu Personenstatistik bei 1, 1 Rechnern pro Person in etwa, sodass man damit rechnen kann, dass so zwischen 1500 bis 2500 Rechner auf der Wiese schnee.
Ja, wenn mehr Leute kommen, dann halt auch mehr. Das sozusagen noch zum Camp. Also wenn ihr noch Fragen habt, wir sind hier im Chat auf www.fritz.de slash fortschatten, könnt ihr auch noch Fragen beantworten. Ja, das soweit sozusagen, erstmal zum Camp.
Wann bist du?
Kommst du morgen zum Club? Ich weiß noch nicht genau, je nachdem, wie wach ich dann bin. Also ich denke ja.
Nochmal danke für den Alias, weiser als CampCCC.de.
Ähm, hier ist Chaosradio. Hallo Andreas.
Und zwar sitze ich hier gerade zu Hause, ich übernehme eine Sendung und erstmal schaue gut an Florian, der für eine Prüfung lernt und ich versuche hier gerade Linux zu installieren und bin schon seit fünf Tagen am Verzweifeln, fast am Verzweifeln. Und zwar hast du das so, ich hab mir letztes Jahr mal Susi Linux gekauft.
Warte mal ganz kurz, können wir die Tastatur lassen?
Ich kann es nicht erinnern, die ist voll laut.
Doch, du kannst nicht tippen.
Na geht weiter.
Also dann hab ich mal versucht, die Linux zu installieren und ich muss sagen, bei eurer Diskussion hier mit Windows 98, Linux und Mac, also die App, ich hab ja vor allem gemacht bei mir im Bekanntenkreis, ist das so, dass diejenigen, die dir hier einen PC gekauft haben mit Windows 98, die haben eigentlich keine Probleme, da ein bisschen die Maus zu bedienen und ein bisschen rumzuklicken und der Rest erhält sich von alleine. Solange man nicht irgendwie größere Ansprüche hat. Stimmt. Und welche mit Grafikkarten? Na ja, wenn die Leute jetzt zocken wollen oder einfache Textverarbeitung so persönlich mit Gebrauch, ist doch der PC mit Windows das Ideal. Für jeden, auch noch so dumm Anwender, der kann damit umspringen.
Wobei, da muss ich dir ein bisschen widersprechen. Ich bin garantiert kein Windows-Profi. Ich bin hauptsächlich Mac-User und beschäftige mich trotzdem mit Windows aus verschiedenen beruflichen Gründen. Hab aber irgendwann dann gesagt, ich möchte einen kleinen Laptop. Also, weiß ich nicht, den man wirklich immer dabei haben kann. Und da gab es ziemlich günstige Alternativen, die mit Windows 98 ausgeliefert werden. Ich dachte, egal, dann lerne ich das Betriebssystem auch ein bisschen kennen und so wunderbar. Ich hab dann nichts installiert, was nicht dabei war. Der lief auch prima, eine Woche lang. Und dann gab es dabei so ein... Da kam noch Software mit dazu, irgendwie so ein Virenscanner und noch irgendein Security-Programm oder so. Hab ich die beiden mal von der mitgelieferten CD installiert. Ab da schon wurde das alles schwierig. Also sobald ich die erste Initiation gemacht hab, war es wahrscheinlich mit dem System irgendwas nicht in Ordnung. Ich dachte, okay, macht ja alles nichts. Da ist von dem Hersteller extra so eine CD dabei, mit der man das System wieder so herstellt, wie es ausgeliefert wurde. Und dann war gar nichts mehr zu machen. Also als ich das versucht hab... Das heißt, ich hab die ganze Platte neu formatiert, neu installiert, alles und so weiter.
Also ich kann das schon nachvollziehen. Das sind so Einzelfälle, die man so hört, wenn ihr uns überhaupt nicht klarkommt drüber, sein Rechner jetzt zwei oder dreimal, egal was für ein Rechner das ist, irgendwie zu irgendwelchen Anbindungen dazu, na was weiß ich, Kaufhof, Aldi, Mediamarkt und wer zurückbringen will, weil da absolut irgendwas nicht da ist und wo die dann auch wie ein Schwein vorm Tor stehen und nicht wissen, was los ist. Aber im Allgemeinen ist das doch, wenn das hier in Deutsch ist... Aber im Allgemeinen ist das doch so, so lange das noch Deutsch ist hier bei Windows 98, wovon man ja ausgehen kann, ist das auch, dass man dann sich nur durchklickt und ein bisschen Angaben macht, die nicht von einem abverlangt werden. Also ich weiß nicht...
Entschuldige, aber ich fand irgendwie die... Also Deutsch ist Windows 98 vor allen Dingen deswegen total unbedienbar, weil die Federmeldungen komplett unverständlich waren. Also die Hilfe war irgendwie so unverständlich, dass ich sie teilweise viermal gelesen habe und immer noch nicht erschließen konnte, was da eigentlich gedacht war. Dann habe ich mir die englische Version installiert und damit bin ich zumindest einigermaßen klargekommen.
Ja, das kann sein.
Also Microsoft Deutschland hat sich da wirklich nicht mit rumbekleckert.
Und überhaupt stellt sich die Frage, wie auf einem Planeten das Wetter sonst so ist?
Die Fehlermeldungen in Windows sind sicher nicht immer besonders verständlich. Aber insgesamt muss ich sagen, ich bin eigentlich ein ex-Macintosh-User. Seit 1984 habe ich die Fehlermeldungen auch nicht besser. Es ist doch meistens etwas klarer.
Wenn man die Tabelle hat, dann kann man damit schon was anfangen, was der Fehler nur eigentlich war.
Man kann es erahnen. Man darf das alles nicht so wörtlich nehmen. Man muss wissen, wann das, was da steht, eigentlich Quatsch ist. Und es dann eben ignorieren. Wenn man damit klarkommt, wenn man nicht alles ernst nimmt, was einem der Rechner so erzählt und da so ein bisschen Gespür für kriegt, dann kommt man, glaube ich, auch damit klar. Und ich muss sagen, manche Sachen sind wirklich ärgerlich gegenüber dem Mac. Zum Beispiel sollte man in seinem Windows-Dateilsystem möglichst nichts verschieben. So das sollte man da liegen lassen.
Das ist doch bei Windows auch so. Bei Windows habe ich jetzt Mac gesagt.
Beim Mac kann man die Sachen schön aufräumen und verschieben. Bei Windows, das war eine Sache, da muss man sie halt da liegen lassen, wo möglich ist.
Kann er die verschieben, kann er die verschieben.
Na, hast du dir mal bei Windows 98 die Display-Probe angeschaut? Hallo, wir haben einen Anrufer.
Ja klar.
Was die da so Fachsinnbildchen mit herumschieben, der einfache Mensch, der jetzt zusammen auch ausgebraucht den PC benutzt, der will ja gar nicht verschieben, der weiß ja eventuell noch nicht mal, auf welcher Platte, der weiß vielleicht noch nicht mal, was eine Partition ist.
Ja, der wollte jetzt nicht hinterherhören, wenn irgendwelche Dateien fehlen. Also der häufigste Anruf, den ich vom PC-Benutzern kriege, ist, ja, ich hab dann auf Speicher gedrückt und plötzlich war die Datei weg.
Na gut, wenn man dann noch übersieht, dass man was suchen kann, dann ist... Was ich eigentlich anrufe, ist mal so den Vergleich zwischen Systemen, den ihr so hier so anstellt nebenbei. Da ich ja nur gerade an Linux sitz, also ich muss sagen, Linux ist bei Weitem, also ich bin absoluter Neuling und ich hab auch keine Lust, hier so einen dicken, so einen 5 cm dicken Wellset zu durchstöbern. Und ich versuche mich jetzt da so ein bisschen rein zu stürzen. Und Linux ist für mich bis jetzt noch ein Buch mit 7 Siegeln, obwohl ich mich schon seit 7 Tagen, Tag und Nacht damit beschäftige.
Also in einem hast du definitiv recht, finde ich, oder in zwei Sachen. Das erste ist das so was wie Windows 98, wenn man jetzt einfach nur schaltet die Kiste an und macht alles, was da noch nötig ist von Installation und schreibt und malt ein bisschen und so, dann ist das völlig okay. Damit habe ich überhaupt kein Problem. Das ist allerdings der Stand, den du auf dem Mac seit über einem Jahrzehnt schon hast. Und der sich auch nicht geändert hat, im Gegenteil. Und mit Linux finde ich, das hat man auch gesehen in den Mainstream-Computer-Zeitschriften. Hat auch dieser Linux-Boom, der kurz vor ein paar Monaten war, ganz schnell nachgelassen. Weil das ist kein Betriebssystem für jeden von uns.
Also was mir echt am Herzen liegt im Moment, was ich jetzt hier mal laut sagen möchte, es ist nicht so, dass man sich Linux installiert, dann sieben Tage investiert und dann kann man das. Also Linux ist ein Betriebssystem. Da muss man Zeit investieren, weil es da eben wichtig ist, die Sachen zu verstehen.
Und das geht wohl auch nicht aus dem Aussehen, dass ich mal hier sowas lesen muss, oder?
Nö, noch mal ja lesen.
Ich sehe ja ein bisschen die Zusammenhänge und tipp mal da.
Guck mal, das Problem ist, dass Windows dich versucht davon zu isolieren, dass du verstehen musst, was da eigentlich vor sich kommt. Und wenn du das, du kannst Windows natürlich so ein bisschen vor dich hin bedienen, aber viele Leute finden es einfach wichtig, auch zu verstehen, was sie tun. Und bei Linux ist es eben keine Option. Also es gibt da natürlich auch Ansätze, weil du in den Massenmarkt einfach nur reinkommst, wenn du dem Kunden versprechen kannst, dass sie ohne Detailwissen nicht umgehen können. Aber letztendlich ist das ein Versprechen, was Linux heute einfach tatsächlich nicht einhält. Also wir möchten auf keinen Fall jetzt, was momentan der Trend ist, dass Leute sich die Chip kaufen und da ist eine CD mit Linux dabei. Und die installieren sich das dann, weil das Installieren geht meistens noch ganz einfach. Weil in Zeitungen früher mal drin stand, Linux installieren ist so schwer. Also Installieren ist inzwischen ganz einfach, aber das Bedienen ist ja dadurch nicht einfacher geworden. Und einfach dieses Anspruchsdenken, dass man sich da ein paar Tage mit auseinandersetzt und dann läuft das schon. Das ist nicht gegeben bei Linux. Das ist einfach so, wenn man in Linux und in Windows ein Jahr investiert, dann ist man mit Linux mächtiger als mit Windows. Aber das heißt nicht, dass für alle Anwendungsgebiete jetzt Linux das Betriebssystem wäre. Letztendlich...
Das Schöne an Linux ist, dass man alles, was man vielleicht erfahren möchte, auch erfahren kann. Das heißt, der Neugier sind da keine Grenzen gesetzt. Und bei Windows sehr wohl, wenn man nicht an irgendeiner Stelle Microsoft-Mitarbeiter wird, kommt man an bestimmten Stellen nicht wirklich weiter. Während bei Linux der ganze Quellkod da ist. Nur in der Praxis sieht es dann aber auch so aus, dass man manche Sachen, die in Linux drinstecken, auch lieber gar nicht verstehen will.
Das ist richtig. Was ich sagen muss, ich benutze nun tatsächlich alle drei Betriebssysteme. Ich hab irgendwie einen Windows-Computer, ich hab auch eine Partition, da ist ein Unix drauf, da ist eins FreeBSD drauf, ich kenn keinen Linux. Und ich hab mehrere Macs.
Du kannst mit Macs alles am besten umgehen.
Nein, ich bin die User. Ich bin niemand, der jetzt irgendwie extensiv programmiert oder sich irgendwie intensiv mit der Konfiguration der Systeme beschäftigt darüber hinausgehen, was ich irgendwie brauche. Was ich aber festgestellt habe, ist bei Betriebssystemen, die ich nicht selber beherrsche, also letztmal abgesehen von MacOS, ist die Effektivität eines Gurus auf einer Linux- oder FreeBSD-Maschine weitaus höher als auf einer Windows-Maschine. Wenn ich mit einem Windows-Problem zu einem ausgewiesenen Windows-Guru gehe, ist der in 80% der Fälle auch nicht in der Lage, dieses Problem zu lösen, was sich um ein richtiges Scheißproblem handelt. Bei einem Unix-Problem finde ich so in 95% aller Fälle innerhalb von wenigen Stunden eine Lösung, die mir jemand sagen kann, guck mal da und geh mal da rein, machen wir mal das und das, oder guck mal auf diese Website, da ist erklärt, wie das geht. Weil in der Regel sind halt Windows-Probleme Inkonsistenzprobleme, wo halt irgendwie irgendein Mist halt irgendwie nicht richtig dokumentiert ist, wo irgendeine API falsch ist, wo irgendein Pointer irgendwie in den Wahlzeiten solche Probleme, wie sie halt bei Windows immer mal wieder auftauchen. Während bei Unix sind es meistens nur Probleme, weil das es irgendwie schwierig ist, das jetzt zu finden, wo es ist und man jemand fragen muss, wie es denn nun eigentlich geht. Manchmal ist die Lösung halt etwas alkalner, aber es gibt in der Regel eine Lösung. Und das finde ich eigentlich dem beeindruckend, einen Unterschied zwischen den beiden Systemen aus User-Sicht.
Ja, man muss auch sagen, wenn man seinen Computer benutzt, weil man gerne ein Gefühl der Zufriedenheit haben will, die Zufriedenheit ist bei... Naja, es gibt Leute, die das tatsächlich als Ziel haben, die bezeichnen sich gewöhnlich als Hacker. Also man kann natürlich unter allen Systemen Zufriedenheit finden, aber wenn du so das Ziel hast, tatsächlich bei jedem Tastendruck zu verstehen, was da passiert, dann kommst du unter Linux am weitesten, weil es einfach für alles Quellcode gibt. Auch bei FreeBSD ist das gegeben. Also wenn man tatsächlich verstehen will, was man tut, dann ist Windows eben einfach nicht das richtige Werkzeug. Also es gibt auch für Windows Debugger, mit denen man den Kernel tracen kann im Assemblermodus. Das kann man auch tun. Und es gibt auch Leute, die das mit Windows echt auskennen. Das wollen wir überhaupt nicht in Abrede stellen.
Ja, wie sieht es aus hier mit den Hardware-Resourcen, also sowas, was ich gelesen habe, Linux nutzt, wo die Hardware effizienter, effektiver, oder man als Linux-User kann man...
Nein, das ist nicht so user-spezifisch. Also Hardware-Resourcen sind auf Servern eben wichtig. Ich habe ein Mailing-List und Web-Server gehabt auf einem 386SX16 mit 8 MB RAM, der hat pro Tag mehrere 10.000 Mails verschickt. Und das ist eben eine Sache, wo Linux echt weit vorne ist.
Ja, und das ist ja generell auch, dass sich mittlerweile im Serverbereich Linux durchsetzt. Vorne liegt wiederum Spezialanwendung, aber es ist einfach stabiler und für Serverzwecke in der Regel angenehmer für die Leute, die den Server betreiben.
Was sagt ihr denn? Lohnt es sich dann auf, wenn für mich hier als jemand, der einen einzelnen PC zu Hause zu stehen hat, noch ab und zu mal ans Internet geht, sich hier so Linux, sich eingeht mit Linux zu beschäftigen, mal davon ab, dass es jetzt meine persönliche Neugier befriedigen könnte, wie sich einige Probleme jetzt hier mit meinem System haben.
Wenn du Neugier hast, also deine Neugierigkeit, bist du auf alle Fälle Linux.
Na, ich sehe das hier nämlich auch schon. Man kommt an keine Stelle, an irgendeinem Ende an. Das wird immer irgendwie, und in der Dokumentation steht das auch, dann suchst du mal da irgendeine Datei.
Ich warte mal anders. Hast du eine Freundin?
Im Moment nicht.
Dann beschäftige ich mich mit Linux.
Warum bist du so geweiht?
Das stimmt aber, oder? Also du wirst viele schlaflose Nächte vor dir haben. Okay, ich sag okay, dann nehmen wir den nächsten ran. Das war nicht gemein, das war wahr, das stimmt.
Man kann auch mit Freundinnen Linux haben. Also das sag ich jetzt einfach mal aus Erfahrung.
Die Frage ist, es muss umgekehrt lauten. Ganz schön, wie wir vom Thema Microsoft wieder weggekommen sind.
Nein, wir sind halt konstruktiv eigentlich so im Tiefen unseres Herzens. Wir meckern zwar gerne mal, aber eigentlich wollen wir den Leuten von verkaufen.
Wie ist das konstruktiv? Komm, wir müssen mal nach draußen gehen.
Das Schwierige ist ja auch, dass man jemanden, der mit Microsoft voll zufrieden ist, das ist ja deswegen, weil er noch nie was anderes benutzt hat meistens. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Für mich trifft das überhaupt nicht.
Vor allen Dingen viele von diesen Leuten haben halt also bei den PC-Rosern, die haben halt sich mal ein Phobos-PC gekauft, mit OS2 vorinstalliert, haben da irgendwie zwei Wochen lang rumgeklickt und sind danach irgendwie gefestigte Microsoft-User. Das kann sich IBM wirklich als Verdienst auf die Fahnen schreiben. Weil irgendwie das war einer der größten Debakel, die sie sich jemals geleistet haben. Ich meine, es gibt natürlich immer noch so Konvertiten wie Pavel, die dann halt vom wahren Glauben abgefallen sind.
Was machst du hauptsächlich, Pavel?
Nicht rechtzeitig einen schnellen Mac kaufen konnten.
Naja, programmieren und Dokumente schreiben, Excel, klicken, alles, was man eigentlich mit einem Rechner macht. Ich meine, ich habe auch Linux natürlich drauf. Ich bin, wie gesagt, 15 Jahre eigentlich drum rum gekommen, irgendwie sowohl Intel-Hardware als auch Microsoft-Software zu benutzen. Aber ich muss sagen, mittlerweile so die meisten Vorurteile, die ich hatte, haben sich einfach mittlerweile als gegenstandslos herausgestellt. Ich bin eigentlich relativ zufrieden. Überraschung liegt es auch daran, dass ich immer nur so viele Gräuelgeschichten darüber gehört habe. Ein paar Gräuelgeschichten sind wahr, gebe ich zu. Aber mittlerweile kann ich so nicht bestätigen. Die Systeme sind wirklich performant, stabil mittlerweile. Und es gibt auch einige Teile, wo wirklich gute Leute dran gearbeitet haben, wo viel Hirnschmalz drinsteckt. Wenn mal ein paar.
Du bringst immer so als Tentative Verkaufs- und Marketingausdrücke und sagst, ich habe kein Problem, deswegen ist es gut. Das zielt nicht.
Genau, Butter bei die Fische, Pavel.
Genau, bring mal Argumente.
Bei welchen Teilen Faxen machen Leute dabei?
Fakten, Fakten, immer die Hörer denken, das Entwicklungssystem zum Beispiel.
Also ich habe ein Projekt gemanagt, in dem Leute unter Windows entwickeln mussten. Sie haben dabei Microsoft-Werkzeuge benutzt. Die Produktivität ist daraufhin dramatisch eingebrochen.
Was haben sie vorher benutzt?
So, dann haben sie angefangen GCC zu benutzen, dann ging es ein bisschen besser. Und dann kam es an die kritischen Teile, wo es so ein bisschen so an den Scheduler ging und darum, dass es irgendwie hintereinander wegperformen sollte und solche Geschichten. Also nicht nur irgendwie Stoßweise, sondern halt Streaming-Geschichten. So, und dann ging es erst wieder weiter, nachdem ich ihn dann in einen Debugger gekauft hatte, mit dem sie dann so auf Bytecode-Ebene unten in den Sourcen teilweise vom Körnerl rum gefrickelt haben, um irgendwie dieses Problem zu lösen.
Sag doch Soft-Ice.
Ja, Soft-Ice, genau. Also, also mittlerweile muss ich zugeben, muss ich zugeben...
Visual Studio, die Microsoft-Umgebung auf Microsoft und halt unter Linux GCC.
Also mittlerweile ist das Visual Studio tatsächlich besser geworden, das muss ich zugeben, aber irgendwie am Anfang war irgendwie dieses Virgil C++ nicht zu vertragen. So schon allein die Art und Weise, wie sie die Dokumentation da drinnen verwurstet haben.
Gut, es gibt...
Klar, ich behaupte nicht, dass es perfekt ist und allein seelig machend, aber nur der Großteil der Kritik, die so geäußert wird. Also man kann gut damit leben.
So, das ist... Also, ich meine, eines der Probleme ist halt irgendwie, dass man... Also Programmierung erfordert ja immer eine konsistente und vollständige Dokumentation und genau das ist eines der Probleme, was halt irgendwie bei Microsoft überhaupt nicht gegeben ist. Ich meine, es gab halt irgendwie kein... Also es gab richtig jahrelang, jahrelang gab es kein Buch, in dem die Architektur von NT transparent erläutert wurde. So, wie es jetzt vor anderthalb Jahren gab es dann zum ersten Mal ein Buch, in dem irgendwie drinsteht, wie NT tatsächlich irgendwie architektonisch aufgebaut ist und wie die ganzen Module ineinandergreifen.
Na, man kann tatsächlich auch die Sourcen kaufen. Also das weiß nicht jeder, aber man kann die Sourcen kaufen. Das kostet zwar richtig Geld bei NT, aber NT ist eigentlich auch so ein bisschen, auch nur so 6-stellig, so was ich weiß.
Aber jedenfalls, ich meine, es gibt natürlich einen Punkt, der auch noch ganz wichtig ist. Windows ist einfach entsetzlich unsexy als Betriebssystem.
Okay, es ist uneasthetisch, dass es wahr ist.
Also es ist auch, was mich zum Beispiel mal wundert, vielleicht kann mir das jemand erklären von euch, ich programmiere ja nicht selber, zumindest nicht NC++, warum zum Beispiel bewegt sich die Maus und auf jedem Windows-Rechner so komisch. Also beim Mac fließt die, bei Windows ruckelt die.
Und beim Mac liegt das daran, dass sie schon ganz, also von Anfang an auf Interrupt-Level die Maus realisiert ist. Das heißt, die läuft auch noch, wenn der Rechner ansonsten steht.
Das ist bei Windows auch so.
Und naja.
Nein, es ist bei Windows tatsächlich so, dass du den Rechner komplett zum Stillstand bringen kannst, wenn die CPU langsam ist und du die Maus schnell bewegst. Weil der Rechner im Interrupt, dem Grafik-Traber sagt, er soll die Mausgräser bewegen, wobei du bei Windows mehr Indirektionen noch dazwischen hast.
Da hast du den seriellen Treiber, also es sind mehr Schichten, einfach mehr Betriebssystemsschichten dazwischen. Aber ich finde, es ist auch besser geworden. Also ich fand, vor zwei Jahren fand ich die Mäuse noch absolut unbedienbar. Aber ich finde, mittlerweile so mit Windows 98 komme ich so auch als Ex-Mac-User mit der Maus ganz gut klar.
Was ein bisschen schade ist, wir haben jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde Sendung, was ein bisschen schade ist, dass wir das eigentliche Problem Microsoft bisher überhaupt nicht angesprochen haben.
Die Praktiken, die Business-Praktiken.
Die Business-Praktiken und vor allen Dingen die Gefahr der Machtstellung, die Microsoft inzwischen hat. Und zwar nicht nur im Computermarkt, sondern dadurch natürlich auch in anderen Märkten. Da haben wir uns wieder mal ein bisschen verrannt. Denn da sehe ich ja die eigentliche Problematik, dass Windows inzwischen in Märkten drin ist, wo man sich fragen muss, ob da so ein quasi Monopol wirklich gesund ist und wozu das führt. Da sind wir ein bisschen wenig draufgekommen. Vielleicht sollte man dazu nach dem Versuch, kurz Info, noch ein paar Sätze sagen.
Genau, und die am meisten beängstigende Sache, wo ich Microsoft bisher gesehen habe, war in Siemens Handys. Wenn man da meinen Sweeper anmacht, dann steht da eben von Microsoft. Und wenn ich mir vorstelle, dass in einem Handy, was ich dabei habe, damit ich immer erreichbar bin, wo es also darauf ankommt, dass die Software nicht abstürzt und zuverlässig funktioniert, wenn ich da Microsoft sehe, da wird mir schon schlecht.
Gibt es eigentlich Flugzeuge von Microsoft-Produkten? Noch mal die Einschätzung Neubauten von der neuen EP. Und das hier ist, was hören wir denn da? Helium! Hätte man ja auch so erkennen können.
Wenn Fritz in Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
0, 32.
Kurz Info.
Reise. Die Bundesregierung will Israel und die Palästinenser bei ihrem Friedensprozess unterstützen. Das sagt der Außenminister Fischer bei getrennten Treffen mit der israelischen Regierung und Palästinenserpräsident Arafat zu. Unterstützung. Die notleidende Bevölkerung im Kosovo erhält rund 3, 7 Milliarden Mark internationale Finanzei für den Wiederaufbau. Darauf verständigten sich Vertreter von über 100 Staaten und Organisationen auf der ersten sogenannten Geberkonferenz in Brüssel. Boat People. Die italienische Küstenbarrad hat heute ein Schiff mit fast 890 Roma-Flüchtlingen aus dem Kosovo aufgebracht. Es wurde rund 60 Seemalen vor der Küste entdeckt und in den süditalienischen Hafen Brindisi geschleppt. Finale, der voraussichtlich letzte Außenbordeinsatz an der russischen Raumstation Mir, ist erfolgreich verlaufen. Während des fünfstündigen Ausstiegs aus der Station montierten zwei Kosmonauten eine Antenne und zwei Messgeräte. Am 28. August sollen die russischen Raumfahrer und ihr französischer Kollege auf die Erde zurückkehren. Fußball, der Hamburger SV, erreicht im Halbfinale-Hinspiel um den UI-Cup beim türkischen Meister Trabzon Spur ein 2 zu 2. Eins zu eins trennte sich der MSV Duisburg vom französischen Teilnehmer SC Montpellier. Moscow, 13 bis 9 Grad, tagsüber wieder sommerlich bis 28 Grad. A11, Oranienburg, Richtung Charlottenburg zwischen Schulzendorfer Straße und Seidlstraße ist an einer Baustelle der rechte Fahrstreifen gesperrt und A10, Kreuz Schöneberg, in Richtung Potsdam zwischen Rangstorf und Heldow, Sperrung der Fahrbahn nach einem Unfall.
Fritz präsentiert das durchgeknallteste Konzert der Freiluftsaison.
Helge Schneider and the Firefuckers. Open Air und Live in Berlin.
Samstag, 4. September in der Waldbühne. 4.
September, nicht vergessen.
Waldbühne.
Ich präsentiert von...
Das ist ja eine völlig andere Generation.
Fried, ich selber komme auch.
Das ist extrem schön, finde ich, kommt von der Einschutze Neubauten, da gibt es eine neue EP, also vier Stücke, nennt sich Total Eclipse of the Sun und so heißt auch dieses Stück, das war die New Vocal Version. Und ihr hört immer noch Chaos Radio Computer Blumen bei Fritz, jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat, wenn es dann nicht ausfällt. Heute ist die 41. Sendung, ne?
Genau.
Dann wisst ihr ja, dass die nächste Sendung die 42.
ist. Da geht es dann um die Fragen, die im Leben wichtig sind.
Richtig.
Nämlich die nach dem Universum, dem Leben und allem. Genau. Und wir telefonieren noch. Wer ist denn da dran?
Alex.
Alex, hallo.
So, ich hab mal ein paar Fragen, ja? Wann ist denn genau euer cooles Treffen? Der Watt, den ihr da veranstalten wollt?
6. bis 8. August.
Was ist neu für einen Tag?
Ja, schwierig zu antworten.
Kannst du nicht Zeitansage anrufen?
Also genau, ruf einfach die Zeitansage an, dann nächste Woche.
Ansonsten alle Infos unter www.ccc.de slash camp, falls du kein Internet hast, 6. bis 8. August.
In Alp Landsberg.
Ja, wo ist denn das da in Berlin?
Ist so östlich, Matsahn. So Richtung hinter Matsahn. Bisschen genauer, findet man das leicht, oder wie? Na ey, guck mal, im Plan brauchst du schon. Stehen die GPS-Koordinaten, kauf den GPS, tipp die da ein und dann weißt du, wo du hin musst. Ist ziemlich einfach.
Oder du steigst in ein Taxi und sagst, du möchtest gern zum Camp. Grüß dich. Ich will mal was zur Vormachtstellung von Microsoft sagen. Ich hab mir jetzt mal VMWare für NT runtergeladen, die Beta, und da hat es rumgemerkt, dass ich keinen Internet Explorer installiert hab. Ach guck mal. Moment, du willst unter NT ein anderes Betriebssystem auch noch laden? Das ist doch mal der Ernst, oder?
Da kann man richtig hübsche Sachen mitmachen mit diesem VMWare für NT.
Piep, du meinst irgendwie gleich zwei Systeme zum Absturz bringen? Ich mein, der Vorteil von VMWare ist doch...
Lass uns doch erstmal kurz etwas erzählen, was er erzählen wollte. Also du hast so ein Beta von einer neuen NT-Version, oder was?
Von der 08, also 08 Beta von VMWare. Und ich hab Netscape installiert, aber der wollte nur unter Internet Explorer 4 oder höher laufen.
Schon interessant. Ich mein, wir haben auch kein Wort über diese ganzen Prozesse verloren, die Microsoft in den letzten Jahren führen musste.
Ich verliere mich doch alle. Du musst mich nicht drüber reden.
Aber gerade die Implementation von Explorer in Betriebssysteme, die ist ja durchaus ein spannendes Thema. Und der installiert jetzt überhaupt nicht, weil du Netscape statt Explorer hast.
Also höre ich, von dem Problem habe ich gerade zum ersten Mal...
Nein, das ist tatsächlich bekannt. Das sagt auch die Webseite, bevor du downloaden willst, dass du das tun musst. Und da haben sich auch schon andere Leute drüber beschwert, aber letztendlich, ich meine, warum würde man ein paar Imple unter NT laufen lassen wollen?
Na, sie benutzen... Na, ich meine, gut, es gibt legitime Gründe, das zu tun.
Na, sag doch mal.
Na, wenn du zum Beispiel einen Webserver so benutzen willst, dass er irgendwie funktioniert...
Na, dann würdest du doch aber nicht NT unter dem richtigen Betriebssystem machen wollen.
Nein, ich meine, es gibt bloß Firmen, bei denen es NT mandatory ist. Und wenn du halt irgendwie in solchen Firmen auch noch was anderes installieren willst, dann kannst du das als Applikation auf dem NT installieren. Da hat niemand was dagegen, aber das Betriebssystem installieren ist immer ein Problem.
Firmen, wo NT mandatory ist, erschießt man sich.
Ja, gut, ich meine, es gibt zum Beispiel große öffentliche, rechtliche Rundfunkanstalten, wo halt irgendwie NT mandatory ist, beziehungsweise Windows-Produkte. Und da gibt es halt immer noch irgendwie die VIM-Ware sozusagen als Fluchtoptionen. Also von daher finde ich es schon ein legitimes Problem. Ich denke, die werden einfach diese Update-Möglichkeit von Internet Explorer benutzen, diese ermöglicht, Applikationen im Windows installieren, die es tatsächlich in Netzgebet nicht gibt. Und deswegen verlangen sie halt genau den Explorer als Install-Funktion. Das dürfte eigentlich genau das Problem sein. Also installier es kurz und irgendwie installier den, vor allem währenddessen, den Explorer wieder.
Wieso der Explorer ist völlig scheiße, nicht nur in Ordnung, der ist einfach mal um Klassen besser als dieses rotte Netscape. Also Netscape ist wirklich schlimm und auf dem PC gibt es überhaupt keinen Grund, Netscape zu benutzen.
Selbst auf dem Mac gibt es nicht wirklich einen Grund dafür, außer wenn man kein Explorer benutzen will. Aber das Problem mit Netscape ist halt, dass deren Code-Basis mittlerweile ziemlich verrottet ist und die da irgendwie nicht wirklich in die Puschen kommen. Aber das Problem mit Explorer ist halt, dass der einfach echt ziemlich viel erzählt. So und da kann man halt irgendwie doch möglicherweise in Probleme geraten, gerade was irgendwie diesen ActiveX-Kram betrifft und so weiter.
Ja und dann wollte ich noch sagen, man sollte ja mal toleranter gegen Windows-Schüler sein. Was heißt tolerant? Ja, denn die haben doch kein Problem damit, wenn du Windows benutzt. Nee, aber das klingt jetzt immer so und ich denke mal, die heutige Zeit ist so hektisch. Die meisten Leute wollen wirklich bloß ein System, weil es halbwegs funktioniert und sich dann groß weiter beschäftigen. Und was hat das mit Windows zu tun?
Ja, das funktioniert ja.
Es funktioniert zum größten Teil.
Das funktioniert auch.
Also meine Lebenserfahrung sagt, dass es...
Es gibt hier mehrere Universen parallel.
Also meine Lebenserfahrung sagt, dass es genau da wo es braucht, über hier abstürzt. Aber ich meine, wenn du eine andere Erfahrung hast, also meine Erfahrung ist, dass Betriebssystem und die Funktionsfähigkeit von Computern im Allgemeinen immer sehr viel mit den Menschen zu tun haben, die sie benutzen. Also Felix zum Beispiel, so jemand, der irgendwie auf alle Nicht-Unix-Betriebssysteme eine extrem negative Computronenausstrahlung hat. Und irgendwie, das funktioniert immer alles.
Dann stelle ich mich daneben und es halt sofort auf zu funktionieren.
Genau. So und bei mir ist halt die Erfahrung so, dass ich mir mit Max extrem gut klarkomme und halt irgendwie meistens mit Windows Probleme habe. Es gibt Leute, die stellen sich vor einen Windows-Rechner, so wie Pavi, und da funktioniert alles prima. Also von daher benutze das System, was irgendwie bei dir am besten funktioniert und alles ist prima. Also ich neige immer dazu, da irgendwie weniger, sagen wir mal ideologisch zu sein, weil letzten Endes irgendwie kommt es nur darauf an, dass mich nicht die Leute mit ihren Betriebssystemproblemen nerven.
Nein, es geht ja auch gar nicht darum, den Leuten jetzt hier irgendwas zu installieren. Aber was ich nicht leiden kann, sind so Leute, die sagen, hey, das funktioniert alles immer. Und wenn man sich da mal neben sie stellt, dann total Absturz, Datenverlust, alles kaputt, Backup hat nicht funktioniert. Und dann ja, das ist jetzt aber zum ersten Mal. Das ist einfach so, dass die meisten Leute es normal finden, dass ihr Computer nicht funktioniert. Und da habe ich was dagegen.
Ich habe mit Erstaunen festgestellt, dass Windows 98 über gewisse Selbstheilungskräfte verfügt. Was? Ja, es war. Ich habe also schon wüste Installationsorgane hinter mir. Und bei einigen hat es auch das System schwer in Mitleidenschaft gezogen. Und so durch mehrfaches Booten heilte sich dann das System von Bootvorgang zu Bootvorgang. Bis nach dem dritten Booten alles wieder in Ordnung war und das Ganze problemlos weiter funktionierte. Ein wirklich guter Tipp war, Windows 98 nicht von der CD direkt zu installieren, sondern erst die CD auf die Platte zu kopieren und von da aus dann zu installieren.
Das ist der Teil immer wieder besorgt von der Platte, ohne dass der CD-ROM-Treiber funktionieren muss.
Das nehme ich tatsächlich für den Trick. Erstens das und wenn man neue Hardware dazusteckt, braucht man nicht dauernd die CD einzulegen.
Vielleicht hätte das auch damit was zu tun. Damit optimiert sind die Turnaround-Zeiten, aber die Probleme gehen ja nicht weg dadurch. Ich kann kurz zitieren, was bei meiner neuen Grafikkarte dabei stand, was ich tun soll, um die alten Grafikkarten-Treiber zu entfernen. Sie gehen davon aus, dass man von NRG 200, von Matrox zu NRG 400 wechselt und die Deinstallationsroutine sagt, rufen Sie FIND auf, FIND im Start-Menü, suchen Sie nach MGA, Sternchen, Punkt, Sternchen, löschen Sie es, suchen Sie nach Matrox, Sternchen, Punkt, Sternchen, löschen Sie es, suchen Sie nach G200, Sternchen, Punkt, Sternchen, löschen Sie es, gehen Sie in die Registry und machen Sie diese drei Verzeichnisse weg, suchen Sie da noch, löschen Sie es. Also, so sieht das aus bei Windows. Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich das selbst teile, sondern im Gegenteil, man muss da echt massiv anlegen.
Auf so einer Anleitung, also bisher hat das Installieren, gut, das Deinstallieren, da bleiben immer ein paar Leichen zurück. Aber die haben sich bisher zumindest nicht schädlich ausgewirkt. Was ich jetzt in der letzten CD schon bedenklich fand, stimmt, dass nach der Deinstallation von Office ungefähr 120 Dateien noch übrig bleiben, die vorher nicht da waren.
Vor allem hat er die Systemdateien editiert und macht das nicht rückgängig.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, alle halbe Jahr oder spätestens nach einem Jahr sollte man sowieso alles wieder neu installieren. Für ein länger hält so ein System eh nicht frisch.
Simon, wir haben Telefon, ne?
Ist schon erstaunlich, was man hier auslösen kann, wenn man sagt, seid mal ein bisschen toleranter, oder? Eine Rede schwallt.
Ich verfolge das schon auch immer so ein bisschen vom Felix, der sagt ja ganz schön rum. Aber ich denke auch mal, das Ergebnis zählt. Denn das ist egal, ob jetzt Mac-User oder einer auf dem Amiga, eine HTML-Seite zum Beispiel macht, die muss cool aussehen und...
Na ja, ich meine, es gibt auch immer so objektive Kriterien wie zum Beispiel Sicherheit.
Wenn du auf jemandem Frontpage, das ist zum Beispiel eine Sache, an der du direkt erkennst, dass jemand keine Ahnung hat.
Dazu nimmt man ja auch Notpad. Der HTML, ne?
Na ja, gut.
Man kann auch wie AI benutzen, zum Glück gibt es den auch für NT. An bestimmten Punkten gibt es objektive Kriterien, die einem Betriebssystem komplett ungeeignet erscheinen lassen. Bestimmte Aufgaben zur Verfügung. Einer davon ist Internet mit Windows-Betriebssystemen. Mit NT geht es vielleicht noch einigermaßen, aber irgendwie die A95 bzw. A98 sind dafür vollständig ungeeignet.
An und von der NT hatte ich auch gar keine Probleme. Das ging spiel. Unter A98 hatte ich Probleme mit dem DFÜ-Netzwerk und dem ganzen List.
Wenn man sich zum Beispiel anguckt, man benutzt eine Webpage, macht da ein Frontpage drauf und benutzt Frontpage-Extensions, zum Beispiel für den Visitor-Account. Was passiert denn? Felix, erzähl doch mal die Geschichte.
Was passiert ist, dass man den Counter sagen kann. Man möchte in der URL diese Art von Ziffern haben und man möchte das gerne in Breite N haben. Man kann sagen, wie viele Ziffern man gerne sehen will. Da kann man zum Beispiel 100.000 zeigen und dann steht die Kiste auch richtig. Und wenn man irgendwie minus 9.999.999 macht, dann steht die für eine halbe Stunde. Also so eine Sache an Microsoft ist einfach nicht nur Lagerquot abzuliefern, der funktioniert, das ist das Problem. Gut, natürlich kann man sagen, manche Leute haben einfach Glück und in ihrem täglichen Leben begehen ihnen diese Sachen nicht. Aber das ist in dem Moment eben weg, wo man Internet hat und irgendwelche Sachen downloadet. Man kann natürlich so eine Aura der Selbstreparation haben, wie Pavel, dass man sich einfach die tollsten Viren installiert und die installieren sich wegen irgendwelcher anderen Microsoft-Bugs selbstständig. Wunderbar! Ich meine, es ist toll, wenn das bei euch so funktioniert. Bin ich da der Letzte, der sagt, installiert euch was anderes. Aber es ist einfach nicht normal. Es gibt da Erfahrungs-Schätze, die die Hotlines gesammelt haben. Es ist nicht so, dass Apple kein Hotline-Problem hat. Das sollte man an der Stelle vielleicht auch mal dementieren. Die Apple-Hotline hat über die Jahre so ein Best-of gesammelt von den schlimmsten Anrufen und die kann man als MP3 im Netz finden. Das ist vielleicht die Hausaufgabe jetzt für unsere lieben Hörer. Lass mal aussuchen, da sind tolle Anrufe. Das ist wirklich echt exzellent. Also es ist nicht so, dass Apple selbst erklären wäre. Man kann alles falsch verstehen.
Was übrigens diese Toleranz betrifft, ich wäre genau in dem Augenblick intolerant, wo mir zum Beispiel vorgeschrieben wird, welches System ich benutzen soll. Zum Beispiel Noris Bank ist eine Bank, die sehr stolz auf ihr Online-Banking ist. Da bin ich hingegangen, weil meine Bank zufällig gerade mit denen fusioniert hat, und habe gesagt, ich will jetzt gerne Internet-Online-Banking machen. Da haben sie gesagt, hier ist ihre CD, installieren sie die zu Hause, alles prima, super Online-Führung, ist sogar ausgezeichnet von irgendwelchen komischen PC-Modern. Da bin ich nach Hause gegangen, hab die in meinem Computergelände festgestellt, das ist eine Windows-only-CD. Ich bin da heute angerufen und hab gesagt, ha so Jungs, ich wollte diese Systeme, diese CD gerade installieren, aber es funktioniert nicht. Dann hab ich sie halt ein bisschen vereilbart und hab sie halt nicht gesagt, dass ich sie auf dem Weg versucht habe zu installieren. Das führt dann zu einem wirklich extrem bizarren Gespräch, das damit endete, dass sie nach ungefähr 15 Minuten fragte, sagen sie haben sie zufällig einen kleinen Abfilter vorne auf ihrem Computer gehabt. Und ich fand das irgendwie eine echt gerechte Rache, weil ich finde es total zum Kotzen, wenn Leute irgendwie nicht auf offene Standards setzen, sondern mich dazu zwingen wollen, halt irgendein System zu installieren, nur um irgendeinen Service zu benutzen.
Aber da kann noch der arme Mensch auch noch hotline nichts dafür.
Ach na, man muss doch den...
Ich mein gut, die werden dafür bezahlt, dass sie da sitzen und aushalten, insofern ich lass mir das dann auch nicht nehmen, die Leute anzurufen.
Das ist halt irgendwie, da werd ich dann tatsächlich intolerant, wenn halt irgendwie bei solchen offensichtlichen Sachen, wie z.B. Webbrowser benutzen könnte oder Java benutzen könnte, dann doch irgendwie so ein Zeugstuff verwendet wird.
Und so ging's mir ja mit VOR und dem Internet Explorer. Genau, ist zum Kotzen, geht zu VMWare und meckert laut. Also anders ändert sich das auch nicht.
Ja, da sollte man auch wirklich echt laut meckern, weil irgendwie dieses...
Tja, fast vorbei Sendung.
Einen noch?
Einen noch.
Ja, ihr mit euren ganzen Diskussionen jetzt Linux und Windows und so weiter, ihr seid eigentlich gar nicht auf die Problematik eingegangen, dass Linux oder beziehungsweise Unix an sich ja immer ein Multi-User-Betriebssystem ist und... Windows ist eine Problematik.
Lass doch Leute erstmal ausreden.
Ja, danke. Ich bin ja schon froh, dass ich so circa der sechste Anrufer an dieser Sendung bin, ein absolutes Minimum bei euch diesmal. Und, na, weiß ich nicht, 27.000 probieren per Handy, wenn ich durchgekommen bin. Aber diese ganze Multi-User-Problematik, jetzt unter Windows, wurde jetzt mit Windows 2000 und Windows-based Terminal Server und und und immer wieder weiter vorangetrieben und aufbauen des Kernels und jetzt endlich wieder eigentlich in diese ganze Richtung, die eigentlich OSU wollte, sprich ein Server und da können sich mehrere Benutzer anmelden. Das ist ja eigentlich in Windows, sage ich mal, stiefmütterlich behandelt worden. Obwohl es eigentlich eine schöne Sache ist, wenn man sich da mal mit beschäftigt hat.
NT kann das ja schon seit einer Weile. Allerdings, wie war das? Ach, sie hat noch so ein hübsches Erlebnis mit der NT Multi-User-Security.
Ja, das war damals der Citrix Windtremen. Also wir setzen die Sachen in der Firma ein und ich betreue da auch ein paar Projekte damit mit dieser Multi-User-Funktionalität. Und da muss man eigentlich sagen, gut, du nimmst irgendein Windows-Programm und sagst, äh, oder andersrum gesagt ein User sagt, du, ich brauch das jetzt hier einfach mal. Du gehst einfach hin, installierst das mal kurz auf dem Server und fertig. Das ist natürlich eine super Sache. Gibt natürlich nicht schon lange, weiß ich, aber...
Also mein Problem mit Windows Multi-User ist halt, dass sie über das Security-Konzept nicht im Mindesten nachgedacht haben. Sie haben halt zwar irgendwie...
Ach, ich glaub nicht, dass sie nicht nachgedacht haben.
Naja, zumindest haben sie Mechanismen implementiert, die nicht wirklich dem Standard, was man an Sicherheit erwarten möchte... Sie haben halt dieses System C2 zertifizieren lassen, im Single-User-Mode und Standalone. Von daher braucht man auch nicht drauf hören. Es gibt halt mehrere Dutzend Methoden, mit denen man Administratorprivilegien erwerben kann auf eine NT-Maschine, selbst wenn man ein extrem unterprivilegierter User ist.
Na gut, bei uns geht es in die Richtung, ich bin in einer Firma tätig, die spezielle Software macht, die in abgeschlossenen Netzwerken läuft, wo kein Internet-Zugriff möglich ist. Und da ist natürlich diese Funktionalität zum Mut-User Windows NT, also C-Trix, Winframe und Windows-based Terminus, Windows 2000, natürlich sehr interessant. Und wenn man sich allerdings wieder mal Windows 2000 anguckt und dann mal so diese üblichen Patches, die man also hat, so Zugriff auf einen Summer-Server oder Zugriff auf Unix, so mal ausprobiert, dann guckt man auch und sagt, Moment mal, wie so funktioniert die Sache nicht. Also da probiert ja Microsoft ja auch wieder mal, sagen wir mal, irgendwo eine eigene Sache zu installieren, was ich natürlich auch nicht toll finde. Vor allen Dingen, sie unterstützen auch nicht. Also ich bin Microsoft-User, muss ich dazu sagen, und ich entwickle für Microsoft. Aber da muss ich auch wieder sagen, da probiert Microsoft wieder eigene Standards durchzudrücken, was ich an Windows an sich nicht so toll finde. Ansonsten sag ich mal, wenn ich eine reine Unix-Umgebung nehme, auch mal ältere Unix-Umgebungen, wie zum Beispiel Ultrex oder Black Unix, wo natürlich so eine grafische Unterstützung oder die Buggy-Möglichkeiten wie unter Visual Studio C++ nicht vorhanden sind, dann fasziniert mich jetzt schon irgendwo Windows. Und man kann Windows, sag ich mal, auch in bestimmten Punkten kontrollieren. Also man weiß, okay, der Fehler, der führt daher.
Also wir haben mal den Test gemacht. Also Felix und ich waren mal bei einem Seminar von einem großen deutschen Computerhersteller. Und die haben uns halt gebeten, da mal ein bisschen was zu zeigen. Und wir kamen halt dahin und waren nicht darauf vorbereitet, dass wir jetzt irgendwie NT-Hacking machen sollen. Wir hatten halt damit gerechnet, dass da ein paar Unix-Maschinen stehen und hatten uns irgendwie überhaupt nicht auf NT vorbereitet. Und wir haben uns diese Maschine angeguckt und haben ungefähr 20 Minuten gebraucht, nachdem wir irgendwie eine ungefähre Idee hatten, was wir machen wollten.
Wir hatten einen Gast-Block-In auf der Kiste, der nicht schreiben durfte, nicht nach Temp, gar nichts.
Der durfte nichts tun. Und wir haben 20 Minuten gebraucht irgendwie und auch nur, weil die Internetverbindung so langsam war.
Es ist nicht sicher, eine Windows-Kiste wird nicht dadurch sicher, dass kein Internetzugang da ist. Das ist die absolute Oberlüge. Und wenn du das glaubst, dann solltest du ganz schnell irgendwie die Mannschaft als Bedarfer holen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Es geht darum, es ist ein abgeschlossener Netzwerk und es ist praktisch eine Umrebung, die unter Unix und wo Windows NT bzw. Microsoft Excel als Aufsatz dafür da ist, da ich unter Unix in dem Sinne nicht so programmierbare Spreadsheets habe, sprich Excel, um irgendwelche Daten aus irgendwelchen Prozessen, aus irgendwelchen Datenbanken irgendwie vernünftig darstellen zu können, ohne ein Riesenprogramm hierauf anzutreiben.
Das gibt es alles seit 100 Jahren, aber die Diskussion bringt auch nicht so viel.
Gegen das, was so die ganze Backoffice-Suite und was alles zusammenpasst, einfach da sucht man unter Unix lange, wisst man diese Cross-Application-Flexibilität.
Wir waren ja bei diesem Multi-User-Problem stehen geblieben, das war ja sozusagen der Ausgangspunkt. Und gerade, was die Multi-User, also Multi-User ist ja immer ein Sicherheitsproblem. Der Kern, wie so Unix so lange daran rumelaboriert hat, bis Multi-User da benutztbar war, war halt, dass sie Security in den Griff bekommen mussten in der Multi-User-Umgebung. Die Mechanismen, die sie bei NT implementiert haben, ähneln den Unix-Mechanismen weitgehend. Also was jetzt direkt das System und so weiter betrifft.
Das muss man aber auch dazu sagen, dass es ja nicht von Microsoft kam, sondern dass sie die Erweiterung wieder aufgekauft haben.
Ja, plus ich meine, wenn ich dann zum Beispiel der NT-Security-FRQ lese, dass man bitte irgendwie möglichst die POSIX-Kompatibilität disablen soll, damit dieses System einigermaßen sicher ist, dann weiß ich, dass es stinkt wie ein Haufen Scheiße. Also wirklich. Also wir haben irgendwie bei diesem System, da gab es irgendwie einen Gastaccount, der durfte nicht schreiben. Dieses ganze System war so zugenagelt, wie man es irgendwie laut einer Microsoft-FRQ erwarten durfte. Wir haben trotzdem irgendwie, wie gesagt, noch nicht mal eine halbe Stunde gebraucht, dann waren wir Admin auf diesem System. Das war also nicht wirklich ein Problem. Selbst wir hatten zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht wirklich viel Ahnung von NT.
Und wir haben keine Tools dabei gehabt und kein Soft-Ice.
Also nichts dergleichen. Und es hat irgendwie wirklich eine Viertelstunde gedauert, bis wir irgendwie da so weit waren. Und noch mal fünf Minuten später hatten wir den Domain-Administrator zugang. Also das ist wirklich...
Wie war das? Früher hieß es mal, in NT-Enterne nochmal kurz nachschauen. Und Passwörter unter NT sind ja sowieso Schall und Rauch.
Also man sollte dazu vielleicht mal sagen, Diskussion ist jetzt nicht so toll. Die Sendung ist auch gleich vorbei. Wer darüber was wissen will, soll bitte zum Camp kommen. Da werde ich unter anderem mit einem Kollegen ein Vorzweifeln machen, wie man ein NT-Schnellcode macht.
Nein, meine Anmerkung war bis einfach so, wenn man jetzt mal in einem großen Unternehmen guckt, es endet, wie er schon sagt, das NT oder office-Anwendungen sind halt irgendwo zu einem sogenannten Absordostandard geworden, wo jeder irgendwo mitspielen muss, gerade so die Ansprache auf die Dienstsachen. Also man muss den Leuten irgendwo, sag ich mal, Microsoft-konforme Schnittstelle irgendwie zu irgendwelchen Daten bieten. Und man ärgert sich halt immer wieder über die NT-Probleme mit rum. Ein richtig gutes System, gerade so eine Echtzeitdatenverarbeitung, Leitsysteme etc. ist nach wie vor Unix, wobei ich auch eine Stange für NT brechen muss. Solange man keine eigenen Microsoft-Produkte einsetzt, sondern eigene Software einsetzt.
Da lassen wir uns aber noch kurz E-Mail-Adressen austauschen, dann könnt ihr das noch verziehen.
Ich möchte noch mal darauf hinweisen, dass wir dieses Thema, zum Beispiel Authentication Mechanism in Novel, NT und Linux, ist ein Vortrag, der auf dem Camp stattfinden wird, wo dieses Thema noch mal ausführliche Beachtung findet. Es wird auch einen Vortrag geben, den Felix schon erwähnte, zur Konstruktion von Insertion Codes für den Exploit von Problemen auf NT. Es wird einen Vortrag geben, der sich noch mal relativ spezifisch mit der Sicherheitsarchitektur von NT beschäftigt. Also für alle Leute, die da Interesse haben, sei denseits des Camps auch noch mal warm ans Herz gelegt. 6.
bis 8.
August in Adlandsberg bei.
Berlin. Zu einem Dumping-Preis von 150 Mark für drei Tage.
Es gibt noch für die Leute, die zu viel Geld übrig haben und gerne in dem Camp ein bisschen mehr Gutes tun wollen, denen irgendwie ich tue gar nichts und bin kein freiwilliger Tarif für 1500 Mark, was etwa den realen Kosten entsprechen dürfte. Den kann man auch noch buchen, kein Problem.
Wie viele habt ihr davon schon?
Einige.
Einige, ja. Es gibt doch einige Firmen, die ihre Mitarbeiter dahin schicken und sagen, okay, da gibt es richtig Bildung, da erfahren sie, was tatsächlich passiert und wir schicken unsere Mitarbeiter dahin.
Und sagt ihr schon mal Tschüss, ja?
Na ja, eine Sache nochmal.
Nee, 20 Sekunden vor Schluss der Sendung.
Genau, wäre mal toll, wenn ihr mal ein bisschen über diese, auch wenn ihr nicht gerade Microsoft-Fans seid, über diese Memory-Leak-Probleme von irgendwelchen Office-Anwendungen mal ein bisschen was sagen könntet.
Wir haben wirklich ausführlich gesagt, dass Office scheiße ist.
Aber das nutzen alle.
Einmal die Woche rebooten, oder täglich.
Es gibt einen Befehl unter Windows-Based Terminal Server, der heißt Shutdown. Man glaubt es gar nicht, was es unter einem normalen Windows-Anten nicht geben sollte. Und es gibt sogar die Aussage von Microsoft, ein Windows-Based Terminal Server sollte man mindestens einmal am Tag booten.
Na wunderbar, super.
Und dann macht man das und es ist gut.
Schönen Abend, tschüss, tschüss.
So, diese Sendung, dieser Sender wird gleich um...
Unter gefährlicher Minute, nichts beseitigt.
Nein, gebootet, dann gibt es den Night Flight Version 1.0, programmiert von Martin Petersdorf. Der kann dann auch Fragen zum Debuggen dieser Sendung überantworten. Die Telefonleitungen sind weiter offen, und Martin freut sich über alle speziellen Fragen zum Thema Server unter NT, Unix, Linux... Bis dahin spezielle Installationen der Grafikkarte und so weiter.
Southkarte.
Gut, dann kommst du auch zum Camp.
Ich komm zum Camp.
Also wenn ihr uns alle beim Camp sehen wollt, kommt auch vorbei. Es gibt noch genug Platz für die Zelte noch.
Wir haben noch ein paar Eintrittskarten, die wir unter die Leute bringen können.
Ja, es könnte also First-Camp-First-Surf. Also wenn es zu voll wird, wir haben nur irgendwie 5 Hektar oder so, wenn es zu voll wird, wird es dicht gemacht.
Aber zwei, drei Karten haben wir schon noch, also ihr müsst jetzt nicht aufgeben, sondern...
Kommt einfach hin.
Ihr könnt ja auch irgendwo drum rumcampen dann, oder? Nein.
Also wir haben noch eine Reservefläche, aber auch eine Infrastruktur.
Da gibt es dann kein Klo, wollen wir damit sagen.
Genau, das sollst du sagen.
Klo gibt es in der Version 2.0, die gibt es nächstes Jahr.
Viel Spaß bei Martin.
Mein Name ist Johnny und ich sag nochmal, viel Spaß beim Night Flight mit Martin, Red-T-Shirt, Petersdorf.